don't
hey
so
good morning once again dear colleagues
so the sitting has resumed
us
please take your seats
i have a few announcements i was
informed that there are no objections
raised within the conference of
committee chairs
to the recommendations by the agri
committee not to oppose to two delegated
acts
pursuant to rule 111 paragraph six of
the rules of procedure the
recommendations are available on the
plenary webpage
if no objections are raised by a
political group or members reaching at
least the low threshold within 24 hours
following this announcement the
recommendations shall be deemed to have
been approved otherwise they will be put
to the vote
i would also like to inform that since
the adjournment of parliament session on
the 15th of december the president
together with the president of the
council has signed one act adopted under
the ordinary legislative procedure in
accordance with rule 79 of our rules of
procedure the title of the act will be
published in the minutes of this sitting
we now come to the order of business
the final draft agenda as adopted by the
conference of presidents by written
procedure on 14th january pursuant to
the rule 157
has been uh distributed
i also uh would like uh to put to the
house the following proposal for changes
to the final draft agenda with the
consensus of the political groups on
wednesday uh there will be an election
of questions of parliament this second
ballot today will be held from 2 30
until a quarter past three and the
results will be announced at four
o'clock and the debates on this
afternoon of this afternoon will start
at three o'clock instead of 2 30.
due to the impossibility for the
president of the european council to be
present today the debate on the european
council and commission statements on the
conclusion of the european council
meeting of the 16th and 17th december
is cancelled and as a consequence
therefore debates will start with the
report by ms schaldermaser on the
digital services act
a voting session will also take place
tonight uh from six o'clock until
quarter past seven and announcements of
those results will be held tomorrow at
nine o'clock
if there are no objections i think we
can proceed
and we move uh to the next item of the
agenda which is european council
and commission statements conclusion of
the european council meeting of 16th
december and also i would like to to um
talk about the council and commission
statements on the presentation of the
programme of activities of the french
presidency monsieur le presidente la
republique francaise
mr president of the french republic
we're delighted to see you today in the
european parliament hemi cycle in
strasbourg it's the second time this
week
although of course the circumstances are
very different
i
would still like to ask everybody to
think for a few seconds about the late
president sasoli since the 1st of
january france has had the rotating
presidency of the european union a
president
where the
idea of a sovereign europe is crucially
important when we face multiple
challenges health
economic
climate migratory challenges mr
president
you can count on this house
to come up with responses to these
challenges to
stand up for our values when
hostile powers are doing all they can to
weaken and destroy what we are an area
of peace freedom and prosperity you can
count on this house
to be with you
to make the french presidency of the
accounts of the european union a success
and now sir let me give you the floor
welcome once again
madam president
vice presidents
commissioners
ladies and gentlemen normal members of
the european parliament madam president
let me first of all congratulate you on
your election
you've said that we're all thinking
about your late predecessor david sasoli
this morning who like all of us believed
in another europe a europe of values
that does bring us together a europe
built
on a unique model based on freedom
solidarity tradition and progress
this
civilization which has matured over
centuries and for 70 years what we've
been trying to build putting an end to
the constant wars in on our continent
and in this house
expressing in strasbourg the idea of the
will of the people
this europe which
during the pandemic
held firm in terms of developing a
vaccine and economic recovery i'm
delighted and i'm honored
today to be able to speak
to you at the beginning of the french
presidency
and
i'd like to just share some ideas with
you i can't go through all of the topics
i'm sure we'll come up against them
again during the question and answer
period but i want to talk about some of
the
deep convictions which lie behind our
common views and common actions this
europe i've been talking about this
european integration is based on three
main promises one of promise of
democracy
which
is born here in europe and was re-born
recast on our continent given new life
in the last 70 years a promise of
progress
shared by all
and a promise for peace
and europe has kept its word
as far as these promises are concerned
the europe in which we're
living in was marked by some tragic
elements in history but now if we look
at the europe in which we live in these
three promises
are under threat
and we not just in the next few months
but the task of our whole generation is
to respond root and branch
to
these
giving new life to these promises i
started with the promise of democracy
this is something which marks us out as
europeans and the french presidency will
be one which promotes the values which
are ours and
can be often looked at as something
which we have in perpetuity but are in
fact being weakened because we're a
generation which is
discovering again how the rule of law
and democracy can be made fragile
liberal democracy using the word in its
political sense over the last few years
this thing that europe invented people
seem
to think it's getting tired and can't
meet the new challenges but i'm here to
tell you how these last few months have
shown the
management of the pandemic by
democracies with debates in parliament
with a free press
with
research and academic systems which are
open and free has led to decisions which
have been taken which protected our
lives protected the economy much better
than
authoritarian regimes did what we did
was frankly together
show
that this cliche is wrong that our
democracies are weaker that's why we're
working together to protect liberal
democracy
to
uh
electoral processes which are the
subjects of foreign interference to
protect the sovereignty of the people
here we have work
which
will continue throughout the spring with
the conference on the future of europe
the french presidency will along with
germany
we've
the clearer agreement was reached as far
as this was concerned that your
parliament's legislative right
is now going to be important
the rule of law we're fighting for this
simple idea part of the universal human
rights
to protect us from the
people who
get too far too carried away as far as
these things are concerned fundamental
rights it would decide if in a sovereign
fashion by member states to accept this
when they join the european union
what do they want to
call into question that people are equal
that each one has a right to have a fair
trial in a independent judiciary
and
the basic idea
that to be more effective
we need to roll back the rule of law
legitimate changes can be built in
brought in by governments
but that doesn't call the rule of law
into question
all of us
before we joined the european
institutions the principles of which
were set in motion as a fruit of our
common commitment and our common ideas
the end of the rule of law is the
beginning of authoritarianism it goes
back to authoritarian regimes
and they have marked our history only to
badly
there is an ideological combat behind
all of this of course and various
authoritarian powers on our borders are
carrying this fight out and it's
affecting many of our countries you can
see
what's happening
undermining the very basis of our
history
where tolerance
and humanitarianism is the very basis of
our civilization an idea is being pushed
to undermine the sovereignty of our
people so we are going to work against
that we're going to talk
and we're going to defend
the power of the rule of law in every
instance i said through dialogue because
it's not a question
that the rule of law is some kind of
invention made in brussels and the
brussels are the only
the only thing that can run it no that's
not true
it's the result of our common history
there were revolutions
for
over the last century to
people could free themselves from
totalitarianism so the rule of law is
precious
and it's a question of convincing people
again who have drifted away from the
respect of it
and we need to win over them
again
i talked about their unique european
democracy is that also is going to be in
part and parcel of this struggle and i
want our european values which bring us
together which we're proud of and are
our strength we want these to
flourish we had the charter fundamental
rights 20 years ago
the
rule the
death penalty was outlawed throughout
europe then so we should use this
charter to be more explicit on
protecting the environment and
recognizing the right to abortion
let's open this debate freely talking to
our fellow citizens
and give fresh impetus to our rule of
law
making europe even stronger that's the
only way our common political project
can go i mentioned this uniqueness
and it also of course is part of our
solidarity which is also unique
it was invented along with the welfare
state a system of protection covering
all citizens from cradle to grave
this is a heritage of our democracy in
europe
and the pandemic has shown that
solidarity isn't a weakness it's a force
greater than any other because it
allowed us to save lives protect jobs it
allowed us to get together a vaccine for
us in europe it's the spirit of
solidarity that led us as europeans to
be the most open in the world as far as
exporting vaccine as a gift and
i hope that our presidency will continue
that work
that it'll do all it can to make sure
that everybody can have a quality job
better paid
with minimum wages which are decent and
available to all reducing wage gap
between men and women creating new
rights for digital platform workers to
introduce quotas for women in on company
boards
fighting against all kinds of
discrimination
the progress i've just mentioned isn't
simply a empty promise or just words
these are
legal texts which in the next few weeks
will be given out to all of us and which
i hope we can make law during
this
six months we've got the possibility of
doing so let's do it together
and the thing that marks us out as this
promise of democracy is this idea
of
a separate kind of culture what is it to
be
european is to feel
emotion when we see the treasures of
europe
the
fruits of our history
to the beauties of paris to the beauties
of krakow
the
romantic spirit the works of
chopin the poetry of fernando pessoa
it's having a way of being in the world
from our museums to our
cafes that is unique this is all part of
what makes us unique we've got
differences of course
but from
ancient greece to the roman empire of
christianity the renaissance the
enlightenment
all of this has shaped human destiny and
i do hope that we can continue together
to promote this european civilization
universal cultures
respecting one another respecting
people's differences and identities
that's why we propose that our best
historians and intellectuals are brought
together to build
together
the fruits of the common history which
we've lived through
so that's the first point i think to
meet the promise of democracy making
europe over
and
we'll have to work
together on the next six months we want
to make europe a cultural democratic and
educational power
proud of itself able to meet these
challenges
the second promise
is the promise of progress
europe
[Music]
has never thought about simply
maintaining the status quo and sitting
back
we
were built
by a desire to build economic growth and
model for the future
the possibility offered
to
our working and middle classes to enjoy
the benefits of this progress and that
promise has been weakened over the last
few years growing inequality
de-industrialization new challenges
in particular the climate and digital
challenges
have
spread out throughout the continent
and our challenge therefore is to build
a model and a new model meeting these
new
challenges which will allow us to
come through on the promise of progress
and climate is the first challenge
europe is the area where in paris in
2015 universal climate awareness really
began it's the
continent where with its target of
carbon neutrality by 2050 set itself the
most ambitious climate goals on the
planet now
we have to move from words to deeds
transforming our industries in
investing in new technologies hydrogen
batteries
that's what the fact is all about
the commission has come out with some
powerful proposals and we
now have together in the next few weeks
to implement many of these proposals
calling on all the stakeholders through
here and throughout the world to
come help us with the green transition
dealing with the carbon adjustment
mechanism at borders which we've been
working on for years
and having mirror aspects in the trade
agreement so that they do the same that
we're doing that's vitally important
europe needs to adopt
the first law in the world on imports
from the for the fruit of deforestation
so we
need to take measures on these issues as
the first planks in our strategy we'll
be doing this at national level we'll
also be
trying to
make certain that the battle for
biodiversity and against
climate
change works as well we're having an oh
summit on the oceans
very soon where many member states and
the commission have an important
strategy to present because we are a
major maritime power and there too when
it comes to biodiversity we've got an
agenda which we want to move forward the
second
21st century challenge is the digital
challenge the digital revolution we in
europe
believe in the diffusion of knowledge
we
the people are not going to reject that
but our challenge
is a double challenge first of all
to build a genuine single digital market
so that we can create european flagships
and champions
is investing in new technology in new
sectors
as the commission has proposed on many
occasions it's consolidating a europe
that can finance these champions and can
simplify its law so that we can build a
genuine single market a domestic
market which is
huge in scale and at the same time
europe
needs to work with
the digital stakeholders to
protect this enlightened spirit to
protect our rights our freedoms
the respect for people's private lives
battle against hate speech and division
that's why along with you honourable
members of the european parliament we're
going to be putting forward important
texts which need to be completed
texts on digital services which you'll
be ruling on tomorrow and the next few
months we could see the emergence of a
european digital model which
simultaneously will provide for free and
fair competition between stakeholders
and stop platforms killing innovation
and making sure they protect citizens
the second thing when the things we need
to do we have to allow us to provide
economic protection
for digital stakeholders
because sometimes these
champions don't behave as champions
should but also there needs to be a
democratic debate against hate speech
manipulation
when people don't ever seem to take
responsibility for their actions we need
to bring in new regulations that deal
with that
the third challenge
is of course security
the
progress the promise of progress in the
future only
means that we can meet cyber attacks
terrorist attacks illegal migration
as we live in turbulent times we need to
provide a response to these and europe
therefore needs to equip itself not
because of a lack of trust as far as
other powers are concerned no but to
make sure that it remains independent in
a violent world so that we don't that
the whim of others to be free in other
words
therefore we need to make certain we
have control over our own borders and
our own area we've made a great deal of
progress whereas we've beefed up frontex
and the french presidency will try to
reform the schengen area which is at the
base of its original promise of an
area of free movement
protecting our external borders
including
having an intergovernmental rapid
intervention force
but by an agreement between member
states as we did between 2018 and 2021
building partnerships with countries of
origin and countries of transit to stop
the traffickers
and
making a more effective policy which
respects our principles to battle
against irregular
immigration
when it comes to defense we can't just
be content with responding to
international crises
we need to be able to anticipate things
and organize the safety of europe
to meet the challenges we can see many
of them were unprecedented over the last
few years and during our six months
we i hope we'll make
we've seen a lot of progress sorry in
the previous presidency under the german
presidency
defining our doctrine of our own
security
fitting with the times and also having a
proper european defense industry and
seeking
strategic independence without which the
europe of defense is meaningless
and won't even exist you'll have
understood that through this agenda we
want together to build a europe which
will be a power in the future a europe
that can respond to climate
technological and digital challenges
also geopolitical challenges a europe
which is independent and it has
the power to decide its own future for
itself and not to depend on the choices
of the other major powers
finally i mentioned the promise of peace
our europe today
is
confronted with
escalating tension on our
borders
a world which is
winding into deregulation and the
possible
reappearance of
the most tragic thing of all war our
model
which is goes beyond our borders and is
why our founding fathers always looked
outwards beyond europe is to think about
some of our neighborhood policies again
and think about our role in the world to
try to help build
a real
power for balance that's what europe can
do
europe
can therefore propose a new alliance to
the african continent
linking the two sides of the
mediterranean we can't just look at the
subject of migration without looking at
the deep rooted causes and see that we
have a common destiny with the african
continent
it's part of this turbulent world and a
part of the future of that continent but
also part of our own future as well
with the city of underlying and sean
michel we've wanted to hold a summit and
we plan to in february to recast our
partnership with the african continent
we want our african friends to allow us
to help them we've already
by june we've distributed 700 million
doses of vaccine and we want to have a
new
stage
come up with a new kind of alliance with
the african continent first of all
through an economic and financial new
deal for africa which is based on what
we built in may in
europe europe put forward
and
brought out the special drawing rights
of the imf and
coming up with specific investment
proposals as well
secondly an agenda as far as education
health and climate is concerned to help
the african continent develop and
provide new hope for young people in
africa and thirdly a security agenda
european support to be given to african
states who are seeing an increase in
terrorism as we did together in the
sahel
finally
fighting against illegal immigration and
net and trafficking networks as we do we
want to make certain that economic
cultural and academic cooperation
continues to flourish
europe can't
turn its back on the western balkans
either the western balkans are
geographically and historically
for the tragic past and a greater future
at the heart of the european continent
they have wounds
which show us how fragile peace can be
and how strong our union can be that's
why
today
we
want
there too to think about our relations
with the western balkan countries
and
give them a clear perspective of
accession to the european union not
against anybody to try to destabilize
anybody else it's a positive
accession
which we carried out in a reasonable
time frame we are re-modernizing the
procedure of negotiation over the last
few months
and
it's not the present europe with its
rules
which can become
europe between 31 32 33 member states
would be kidding ourselves if we thought
that so in the framework of the
conference and the results expected in
may we need to think about our own rules
again
and make them clearer make them easier
so that we can decide more quickly and
more easily and also politically be
honest
about europe
and a europe where the western balkan
countries have a place we don't we need
to look again at the way europe works
and the shape of europe that's why the
conference on the future of you should
be followed up on a conference by sorry
by a conference on the
western balkans dealing with these
crucial topics
europe and the united kingdom also need
to regain trust in one another i don't
want to speak at excessive length madam
president but i'll just say that
the links of friendship between
ourselves and the people of the united
kingdom are there and will remain
freedom economic and social progress
what we've done together is too much to
just be forgotten but to continue to
move together and work together after
brexit that means that the uk government
needs to commit to itself in good faith
respecting the agreements already
concluded with the union which we will
stick to and we might want to make
certain that the agreements entered into
are respected when it comes to the
rights of our fishermen or the northern
ireland protocol or
the
vital discussions which have to be had
in the future which be clear let's be
tough than say that congress
agreements entered into have to be
respected that's the way to remain
friends europe wants to be an area of
collective security on our continent
the security of our continent requires
strategic rethinking for europe
strategic rearming of europe as an area
of balance and peace in when it comes to
dialogue with russia in particular this
dialogue is something i've been standing
up for for many years it's not
just
a vague idea because we're so close
together sometimes for us and for russia
for the very security of our continent
which is indivisible we need this
dialogue we need in europe collectively
to set out our own requirements and make
certain that they are respected and we
need to be in a position to make that
happen we need to be decisive when it
comes to destabilization manipulation
interference
what we need to build is a european
order based on principles and rules
which we can rally behind and which we
put together not against anybody not
without anybody but with russia 30 years
ago
let me remind you of that rejecting the
cause to force coercion threats free
choices of states to accede to alliances
or bodies that they wish to do so in
viability of borders
territorial integrity of states
rejection of spheres of influence what
i'm talking about are the principles
which we europeans and russia signed up
to 30 years ago
we in europe need to stand up for these
inherent rights as which are part of the
sovereignty of state it's up to us to
reaffirm these values and effectively
punish violate those who violate them
this is at the heart of our european
project security and it's a response to
the destabilization which some people
are trying to undertake on our continent
that's why we'll continue with
germany
in the normandy form is a look for a
response to the conflict in a solution
to the conflict in the ukraine which is
crucially important at the moment and
your collective support ladies and
gentlemen is vital to achieve that
that's why we will make sure that europe
makes its voice heard it's single voice
heard when it comes to strategic
armaments
conventional weapons the transparency
military activities and respect for the
sovereignty of all
european states no matter what their
history may be over the next few months
we should come up with a european
proposal
building a new order of security and
stability
we should build this as europeans
working with other europeans working
with our allies in nato and
then
propose it for negotiation with russia
honourable members of the european
parliament
i was born in 1977
and i saw europe all around me as i was
growing up
i grew up in northern france
and europe meant peace it was just
obvious
you didn't have to think about it
like a lot of you here i saw a lot less
euro skepticism the 2005 record
referendum the idea that europe was just
a technocracy
delocalization sovereign debt crisis
our
generations today
need to recast
our europe so that it meets its promise
of being a democracy
providing progress and providing peace
we need to give ourselves the means to
make europe a cultural democratic and
educational power power for the future a
power for balance
in order to do that
we have a number of crucial texts to
approve over the next weeks and months
of i count on the close cooperation with
the european parliament
bearing in mind these texts and these
shared ambitions
all together
faced with the tyranny of
feeble ideas
we need to come up
with the
what unity really means the desire to
take the long view and be bold when we
need to
robert schuman talks about creative
efforts not
banning things not making things too
easy
these
creative efforts built europe neither
the policies from before the crisis or
what we used to do then or
the reflexes of the past going back to
nationalism dissolving our identities
none of those things will fit the coming
world
our capacity though to innovate to
invent
to make a dream possible to make it
real and make it useful to our fellow
citizens that's at the heart of our
success
we
have
the strength we have the means
that's why i believe in us thanks very
much
[Applause]
i give the floor now on behalf of the
commission to vice president secretary
you have the floor
madame
president of the parliament president of
france members of the european
parliament it is
a pleasure
to speak at the start of
this debate
and i'd like to congratulate you my dear
roberta on your election as president
now i know that president fond du lan
regrets not being able to be present
here today in person
and that reminds us once again that the
kovid 19 pandemic
is still very present in our lives
i'm nevertheless certain
that she shares my feelings today
i'm pleased that europe can count on the
experience and wisdom of france
during the coming months
we
will be living through a crucial time in
our history
the french presidency begins
in
an agitated geopolitical context
and indeed
you only need to look at our immediate
neighborhood there is just a short plane
ride away couple of hours where security
architecture of our continent is being
challenged
we see old failed
ideas re-emerging of power block
competition of spheres of influence and
we europeans are
resolutely opposed to
entire countries being once again
treated so distantly as mere backyards
we categorically reject the threat of
use of force
one of the fundamental principles that
underpin european security as enshrined
in the helsinki final act
and we stand ready to take action if
necessary
and we have made clear any further
military aggression against ukraine will
have massive consequences and severe
costs
at the same time we welcome the recent
diplomatic activity
from u.s russia talks to the nato russia
council and the oec meeting and the
commission remains in close contact with
the u.s administration
we europeans will do everything in our
power to protect and nurture our model
of peaceful democratic governance
and its central tenants of dialogue and
diplomacy
we will strengthen
will strengthen it from within
and protect it against outside threats
from cyber attacks to hybrid threats
such as we have seen recently
on the border with belarus
for this two projects will be
particularly important in the coming
months with the strategic compass our
new european white paper on defense will
set out our common strategic vision
while the defense package we aim to
strengthen our capabilities and i know
how my colleague high representative and
vice president joseph borla is working
closely with the minister ledrion and
all the ministers of foreign affairs and
defense in that respect mr president
macron has made very important
remarks on the importance of eu africa
summit also we in the commission are
looking at this occasion as a
possibility of the new beginning the new
new start in this very important
strategic relationship
we very much appreciate
your remarks on the western balkans
because they right rightfully so should
be on the top of our priority lists
and we've been of course listening very
carefully about your
wise words on our relationship with
united kingdom
united kingdom
they are our
neighbors
our allies and i think all of us in this
house would like to see them again as
our strategic partners
for that to happen we need to rebuild
the trust and trust is being built
through respecting the agreements the
agreements which in recently signed and
ratified be done withdrawal bid on trade
incorporation or bid proper
implementation of the protocol on
ireland and northern ireland and we on
the side of the european union on the
side of the commission will show all the
flexibility all the goodwill to make
this happen but we need a good partner
on other side mr president you've been
highlighting how important our unity and
cooperation in the world is
and i'm very glad that the french
presidency is going to focus on all the
important priorities because the world
around us
is indeed becoming more unpredictable
and europeans rightly expect us to
protect them
honourable members ladies and gentlemen
the need to focus on threats of today
and the challenges of tomorrow is of
course also true for the european
economy
despite the pandemic we have already
embarked on the modernization of the
economy and the society towards more
sustainable way of living and working a
way of living that preserves both the
health of the planet and the livelihood
of our people that is our economic
growth model for the next 10 years and
beyond
we have already built a solid foundation
for this through next generation eu
it is 800 billion
euro recovery program we are not only
investing to fi to finally put the
pandemic behind us we are also investing
in our sustainable and digital future
we are tackling the structural
challenges of our economies while
ensuring that everyone can benefit from
this future
large companies as well as our small and
medium-sized enterprises farmers as well
as low-income households
and the early success of our approach is
already proving us right
studies show that thanks to the next
generation eu growth in europe is 1.5
percent higher than it would have been
with national recovery programs hello
new model the croissants
our
new growth model needs to guarantee
economic political and technological
sovereignty for europe it needs to
enable our businesses and our single
market to fully benefit from new
opportunities
and that's why we want to
bring technology back to europe ensuring
that the smallest semiconductors in the
world are manufactured here in europe
and that's exactly what we're going to
do with the european chips act that we
will be presenting during the coming
weeks they're important for the
computers of the world
and in all kinds of technology without
chips there is no digital world and i
know my colleague
executive vice president vestasia
commissioner breton who are also here
with us today will agree with what i say
on that
i'm delighted
that
france
is
ensuring
the strat strat uh supply stains chain
strategies and independence are a key
point of its presidency
we need to move into new areas and forge
our own destiny by ensuring we have a
long
term view
we also have legislation on digital
markets
and digital services the digital market
act and the digital services act
they are the pillar of our european
digital strategy
we're going to
limit the powers of internet giants
so that we can ensure that competition
remains fair particularly for
small and medium enterprises because
they are those that drive innovation
here in europe they're the ones that pay
taxes and the ones that take on board
social responsibilities
ladies and gentlemen
there was no doubt in simone vale's mind
that
a
union
of democracy is the most powerful and
most resilient form
of governance possible
during the coming months of the french
presidency we'll be working
extremely hard to bring
our europe closer to the europe that she
dreamed of
and deliver sustainable growth
united we will defend our values and
strengthen our security
and united we will work for the benefit
of all europeans each and every day and
this is exactly what such a great
europeans like david cecily would like
us to do thank you very much merci
beaucoup
thank you very much vice president
zefkovich we now move to the speakers of
the political groups we start with
manfred weber for the group of the epp
madame president
sounds good
mr president
welcome and thank you for your speech
france is ready
and after your speech i'm sure that
europe will be in good hands in the next
six months
the priorities are well said and if i
may say from an epb point of view i hear
defense i see industry policy as it
chops
you
your presidency will even organize a
conference on the fight against cancer
what i saw so many epp priorities are in
and that's why you can count on the
biggest political family in the european
union to deliver on these issues we need
progress in europe
i want to focus
in my contribution today on more general
considerations
my first consideration is
no more words we need actions now in
europe we listened to your sabon speech
in athens you had a great speech in 2018
here in this house also today
you hear a lot about the vision for you
about severality about a stronger europe
and
i deeply believe in what you say in this
perspective for europe but
in the last five years is europe really
more sovereign than before
every six months we welcome here in this
chamber a new presidency angela merkel
was here prime minister yancha prime
minister costa
for a prime minister it's probably
interesting to be here and to present
ideas on european stage
for us it is a kind of a routine and
sometimes i even must say kind of a
boring routine because we hear on the
big things on the agenda every six
months the same
and that's why the question is can we
speed up and i'll give you
a few considerations a few examples on
this since years we know about putin's
behavior he threatens us he wants to go
to war again about against ukraine
he wants to build up an empire an empire
of oligarchs against our idea of freedom
and the european council let's be frank
is not capable today
to put the form firm stand
uh in today's world on the table no
stream two that's my opinion must be
stopped if there is a military
escalation in the in the ukraine but
what is going on on council side
and after afghanistan in ukraine i think
it's obvious that we need now someone in
the council
who goes to the council and tell them we
have to stop unanimous vote on foreign
affairs issues who will do so who will
do so
take rule of law as another example
article 7 procedure i voted personally
here in this house in favor of an
article 7 against hungary and my party
today is in slovakia in czech republic
in poland with donald tusk the front
runners for rule of law and for a
pro-european approach
that is epp today
but on the other hand i see in council
that article seven procedure is not even
on the table of the council you do press
statements among leaders but when victor
open and when you're sitting together
you are not ready to talk about this and
let's be also clear on the question of
uh
of uh of voting you are even obliged to
vote now on the article 7 procedure on
council but nothing is happening we
fought as parliament for a binding rule
of law mechanism and commission will do
what we asked them to do but the council
is not capable to deliver there are two
examples for
what i say when i what i mean when i say
we need now actions not any more words
that is what europe needs
and
if you let me add another point in
second consideration
i think
we have to consider that in the western
democracy we see more and more splits
and the real big question for us is how
can we keep our societies together
cities against rural areas young
generation against an aging continent
vaccinated people again unvaccinated
people
i try also to explain this on an example
yellow west is not only a french
phenomenon yes we are committed to the
fight against climate change but when we
discuss the issues on green deal now in
the next years we have to take care
about the poor
energy poverty is unacceptable for us in
europe a higher energy costs will also
bring high inflation and that will also
be a problem for the poor in our
societies and that's why
we have to put this subject in the
center of the debate about green deal
otherwise populism will grow and the
transition will fail and that's why epp
will take care about this and allow me
to add a final point a more general
consideration again on this splitting up
about the political concept you know
that i'm a christian democrat my party
as epp we are bridge builders by
definition
in some of your contributions in the
past i understood that you are more
separating between the progressive
and the populists to create this split
in a society
i don't think that this is healthy on
the long run i don't think so i think it
is good to have a competition in the
center of the landscape between
different political ideas among
democrats and not creating the split
towards the populace probably with this
approach we make the populists even
bigger than they are and that's why i'm
happy let me say this as an epp
politician that now is valerie kress we
have a real competition in the center of
the landscape i'm happy about this and
maybe let's see about the french voters
we will make the french voters will make
also gender balance a reality that they
vote the first time for a french
female pro-european candidate
so
that is allowed as a party politician if
i if i may say this way mr president
but what i really like and
yeah yeah yeah what i really like is
[Applause]
what i really like is and mr president
please really seriously speaking what i
really like is your ambitions approach
for europe and especially is the support
for this chamber
210 million people voted 2019 for this
parliament the second biggest democracy
in the world is europe
and to strengthen this institution and
to show that the decisions of the future
are made in this institution
is what we all believe in we count on
you to transform the outcome of the
conference for the future of europe in
reality mr welker mr president welcome
time is running let's keep europe united
and
no more words let's practice actions
thank you
thank you
thank you mr webber i now give the floor
to iracia garcia perez on behalf of the
s d group
gracias president
thank you president
president macron
welcome to the european parliament
the
your rotating presidency of the council
is taking place
at a time
when the pandemic has enabled europe to
take historic steps forward in the
integration project in your new year's
speech you promised a change of
direction in 2022
to achieve a europe that is powerful in
the world
fully sovereign
free in its choices
and in charge of its own destiny
europe will only be powerful in the
world
if it's able to eradicate poverty and
inequalities
european democracy
needs the construction of a social
europe
that curbs the most damaging instincts
of ultra right-wing populism
we need to conclude the reforms that are
on the table such as establishing
minimum wages across the european union
regulating the working conditions
of platform workers
setting out a minimum
wage
or the implementation
of the social fund for the climate
our power in the world will also depend
on whether we're capable of living in
equality
unblock the anti-discrimination
directive support the gender violence
directive and push for the necessary
agreements to do away with the salary
gap and break the glass ceiling
that prevents women from being present
on company boards
you europe will have no future if it
leaves aside the millions of women that
make up half of our population
there will be no present or future
if we don't defend the only tool
able to protect the values that unite us
the rule of law
we need to apply them
their conditionality mechanism and
maintain a commitment not to approve the
polish and hungarian recovery plans
until their governments return to the
path of democracy and comply with court
of justice rulings
a powerful europe
will be the europe that takes the lead
on an energy transition that's fairer
and more sustainable and avoids
disastrous climate change we're aware of
the specific circumstances of france and
germany but the commission's proposal on
nuclear and gas cannot weaken our global
leadership on renewable energies the
only green energy sources
france needs to show powerful
leadership
and take advantage of the european
european response model that was
established during the pandemic
together we set up the most ambitious
recovery plan in the history of europe
worth over 750 billion euros backed up
by pooled debt
now we need to prevent premature
adjustments that would kill off our
economic growth
austerity made the richest richer and
left the poorest worse off we need a
reform of the fiscal rules that fosters
fair growth and supports the public
investment necessary
to support the priorities that we're
establishing in europe such as the green
and digital transitions
the time has come to step up our plans
for a defense europe the withdrawal from
afghanistan the orcas pact and the
crises with russia and belarus
should
mean that we accept the development of
strategic sovereignty
but europe cannot grow within a fortress
we need solidarity with the world and
the parliament continues to hope that
the council will agree the only possible
tool to avoid the deaths of human beings
on our borders
a migration pact which is based on
solidarity
mr macron your presidency won't go down
in history because of your talents as a
speaker
but as a result of the laws that
together
we can
bring forward
we need to move forward rapidly
the motto of your presidency
concludes with the idea of a sense of
belonging
and belonging requires public conviction
put young people and those who are most
vulnerable at the heart of your
presidency and they will never again ask
you to take the european flag down from
the arc de triomphe in paris
let me hold my hand out to you
because the socialist and democrat
family
wants every citizen to feel a sense of
pride when they see the european blue
light up monuments in the towns and
cities of our union
as jean monet taught us
we're not forming a coalition of states
we're uniting people
thank you
thank you very much miss garcia perez
i now give the floor to stefan sejourney
on behalf of the renew group
mercedes president thank you madam
president congratulations once again on
your election
mr
president of the republic commissioner
let me say by way of introduction
that
we need
as manfred weber said uh
more
deeds and fewer words i think we all
agree with that over the last two years
in europe thanks to europe
things have moved forward thanks to
europe we're the most vaccinated
continent in the world thanks to europe
mr president
we've
set up a european recovery plan in
historic dimensions which saved millions
of europeans from
unemployment or precarious work thanks
to europe we are the green continent
we'll be carbon neutral by 2050 and this
will help the world and help people find
work
this is partly owing to the initiative
and can and the commitment of this
parliament also the determination and
ambitions of the institutions mr
president and also to what you've done
obviously everything isn't perfect they
have haven't gone as quickly as we all
as well as we might have liked there are
but you will still be
controversy and europe will as we are
aware be the
convenient scapegoat for those who
refuse to accept the responsibility
work isn't over of course and with the
presidency of the council which you have
just opened we need to move more quickly
i think the whole parliament would agree
with that because the situation is
urgent
it's urgent that we take control of our
own destiny again and
bring in european sovereignty against
the
foreign powers who are trying to
undermine it it's urgent for the planet
we need also it's urgent to get the rule
of law respected
it's an urgent matter for our young
people who are looking to us for new
energy and a new direction mr president
of the republic you have set a course
and my group will be there we'll be
beside you to try to get our rules and
values accepted by the giants of the
digital industry thanks to the digital
markets and digital
services act we'll be with you trying to
go yet further for the planet with the
carbon border tax we want a power more
powerful european defense we want fairer
trade we want
reimagined minimum wages and new
budgetary rules
borders that are better respected and a
recast right of asylum
mr
president
my group would like to add two ideas to
what you've put forward for europeans
first of all when it comes to equality
between women and men we want the french
presidency to be
behind the idea of the simon vale pact
which will call on all signatory
countries to adopt progressive laws when
it comes to parity section of
reproductive rights and the battle
against sexual and sexist violence
but also we want you to be bold with us
in helping
the europe of young people
we've been calling on
our young people to do a great deal over
the last few months we need to be worthy
of them
we want to see therefore a platform
created to help young europeans set up a
business to get involved to find a job
or a training course
it won't be
easy we're aware of that there are still
differences in this house and within
political groups themselves but we in
renew europe are committed to consensus
that's the
lies at the heart of this union we
believe
and the german dutch
and the
political party that my
group belongs to are willing to go
further the majority of this parliament
has voted through an agree agenda for
2024 which is very ambitious we are
willing and ready because i think the
stars are lining up with the french
presidency the commitment is there the
course is clear
let's let the liars and the cynics bray
they want to cling to things as they are
my group wants to fight to
build the future and bring in
a proper united europe more quickly so
law by law bill by bill project by
project reform by reform we are fighting
for a green free proud and fully
sovereign europe the french presidency
is coming at a key moment
everything is in place for it to be a
success and i would recommend just one
watch word be bold be bold be bold
merci
merci monsieur
thank you very much mr c charlene
now for the green group i will give the
floor to janik at janiketo
[Music]
merci
thank you thank you madam president
mr president of the french republic
that was undeniably an excellent speech
everything was in there
sovereignty
european values the civilization project
even the climate and diversity
but
mr president
you've been president of the french
republic for five years and you have
been there by responsible for
a stock take if you like for
europe and for france and we all know
that
global heating is one of the greatest
challenges that humanity is now
confronted by
fires floods drought
heat waves
across the world across the planet
across europe we're all affected by
these things and our very existence is
threatened but fighting for the climate
is not just an imperative for survival
now if europe decides it it could be an
extraordinary opportunity to give
greater
meaning to our economy
to innovate to create good quality jobs
to
manage us territories sustainably to
build a fair society which is
expresses its solidarity and which is
democratic and this is the
uh path that we the greens have chosen
mr president you have chosen a different
path
it's a a path together with hungary and
poland which will kill the climate
promoting gas saving nuclear and
condemning the whole process to
disaster and your climate ambitions have
been sacrificed there and you
in
history mr president will be
the president who didn't take climate
action because at the base of all this
you
would rather have amnesties designed
with other countries than to actually
take up the fight against uh the
challenge of climate change you would
prefer
to procrastinate
like meryl streep in don't look up the
film
thinking about crazy ideas for 10 15 or
20 years rather than to actually set out
as we want to do
how to mobilize generally
the public and it is that public
mobilization bringing
young people together
this young
these young people so terrified by
ecological disaster and yet they have so
much creativity they have so much
inventiveness they have great diversity
and enormous commitment when it comes to
the climate and to social justice
mr president you're quite right
you said
that europe is a civilizing project
it is in fact
a peace project it is a project of
fundamental uh uh of
liberty and democracy and why
about a year ago almost to the day
you were celebrating the
uh investment agreement with china
calling into
um
great risk our companies
and you were celebrating this agreement
at a time when the chinese government
was the chinese regime was
taking steps against the demonstrators
and is continuing to perpetrate a
genocide against the uyghurs
six years ago mr president
six years ago
you you were
talking about uh the courage
demonstrated by angela merkel in uh
hosting syrian refugees and you were
right
you know
on the 24th of november last year 27
migrants drowned in the english channel
are joining
thousands of others who have died on our
borders and amid amongst those victims
there was maryam
maryam was a young kurd
20 years old an iraqi kurd it is these
kurds who stood up against the islamic
state with so much courage that it was
abandoned by the west
this occurred mariam
was trying to reach her fiance
all that she wanted to do was to live
and to love but she drowned
so why mr president
why
do you
every day in calais
decide to pull down the tents
making
these survivors
subject to mistreatment and a loss of
hope
mr president
don't just listen to all of these
theories that say that there's going to
be an invasion let's look at the science
of the great
global heating debate
to be perfectly frank mr president
as you were saying
we diverge on the europe that we
actually want in our europe will never
be the one that you want the one that
turns its back on the climate on
glyphosates that
allows goods and services to
traffic uh
with all of the impacts that that can
have on people
uh and and workers and our europe will
never be the one that in
this house will allow the right to
abortion to be undermined with the
conservatives and the far right in
it is a europe of innovation it is a
europa
democracy and dignity and a europe of
the future and a europe of young people
i hope mr president that that is the
europe that will cause cause you to act
next
next
next
you will understand
you will understand that all group
leaders have
exceeded their time including this now i
say that there's a point of order go
ahead mr
miss garcia perez
well obviously
we all have ideological differences here
but nevertheless please let's be
respectful during today's debate
out of respect for europe and out of
respect for our citizens we'll all have
the opportunity to campaign
and support our colleagues from our
different political groups i'll be doing
the same
but
but this isn't the right
time
when we want to we can meet
our colleagues from our political groups
and campaign but we should have a little
bit of respect for europe thank you
this is a point of order point of order
stefan go ahead
president
a point of order
on
the same thing
as president iraqis just said it's
shameful to turn this hemicycle into a
national parliament it shows a lack of
respect
it disrespects the members of the
european parliament our work and the
debate
political groups
are free
to
organize their speaking time and the
content of what they say as they wish
but i would ask us to be respectful of
speaking time the content of the debate
and all speakers thank you
thank you
thank you the principle of dignity and
respect will be will be observed in this
room in this house i can assure you
thank you
let's go ahead
next is jordan bardea for the id group
[Applause]
thank you president
president
of the republic europe is now 60 years
old that's your europe but ours is 3 000
years old your political project is to
do away with european nations we want to
save them
french
history you mentioned it and you said
you were pleased to find yourself at the
head of an organization that wants to do
away with europe you and your allies
have turned
europe
in to erdogan's clown america the united
states
puppy
and so on for china and africa
the 21st century needs
a greater vision from us during a recent
interview talked about wanting to piss
off a large portion of the french people
and you also talked about migration you
said you wanted to move forward with the
european pact on migration in a press
conference
and this is a legal problem
because it the european union will
prevent member states from defining
their own migration policy
you are going to
implement
family reunification extended to
brothers and sisters
prevent people being taken back to
borders and encourage ngos in their
activities as traffickers
you are
undermining the remaining rights of the
people i.e the right to decide who comes
in and who stays out but what you should
be doing is establishing borders proper
borders in france
and in europe you're instead undermining
the legitimate rights of the french
people to live in their own home
will europe still be europe
if
mosques are everywhere
will it still be europe if people
swear allegiance to the sultans in
turkey and morocco i think this will be
a different civilization and they will
treat women differently to the way we do
europe can survive if there are three
percent budgetary deficit
uh limits but they won't be able to we
won't be able to survive too much
migration
europe cannot be submerged and the
people of europe can't be replaced
the
upcoming summit
will not only decide the fate of france
but that of europe as a whole president
of france how can you say that you
are a reuniting force in europe when
you've divided
france
you have promoted everyone against
everyone
you behaved
like
a liquidator at the head of the french
state
alstom for example will remain a
permanent symbol of your betrayal of our
national
interests
the nation has been weakened in its
sovereignty and the people's identity
and freedoms have been undermined
only your brain will remain
of your promise of a new world your
cynicism and your contempt which has
saddened our people weakened it and made
it doubt
itself and the future france needs to
shine
again to express its power but you
switch the lights out
for france and for europe it's crucial
that you're not re-elected thank you
i give the floor next to rafael on
behalf of the europe of the ecr
honorable
grazie president president macron thank
you madam president president macron
commissioner
in this house this week we've lived
through different emotions and feelings
commemorating the late president so
solely to the election of president
metzola
emotions and feelings are very different
as i said because of course pain and
joy are mingled together and
that i think should really
always though there should be a thread
running through our debates respect
when we talk to one another about the
forthcoming french presidency we need to
do this in a courteous way because on
the main topics of the agenda we have
desires to put forward as well
we talked about the rule of law well the
rule of law
isn't something
which can be used as an ideological
weapon it's not an issue that can be
turned against someone in the next six
months we want there to be a real
discussion to see whether or not the
ideas put forward deserve support and
that means we need an institutional
framework which needs to be clear and
precise respecting the mandate that our
electors gave us and the same thing goes
for other important
dossiers as well we've said how
important the micro issue of migration
is this needs to be dealt with in a
broader way we need to understand what's
happening in africa when europe can play
a role
where china is now moving in
as we move out what's happening in libya
for example there's been a complete lack
of control over the migrant migratory
flows to the mediterranean
and
russia and turkey are playing an
increasingly important role let's talk
about these issues dealing with the
issue of the urgency of migratory flows
and let's do it of course doing a
pandemic where the
measures
for economic recovery have been hugely
important
but we've also got the stability pact
which we'll have to just discuss as well
because that is what will guarantee
whether or not we can consolidate this
economic growth which we have at this
crucially important period and also very
important other priority climate where
we need to be realistic
not just looking at the present socially
on-prem
entrepreneurial
approach that our continent has we need
to be up there with the big producers on
a world level so
we have different positions on some of
these issues mr president of course but
that feeling that we've had in the last
few days shouldn't leave us respect
and
polite discussion of differences we have
we believe that our ideas have power our
proposals have power and we can do that
with the conviction that we are bringing
together
a project that isn't against anybody not
against europe we are here because we
want to build a europe that's different
we want to change the way europe runs
and the way europe works discussion and
debate will bring that about we'll be
making proposals to that end they're not
against anybody we're pushing forward
our ideas convinced certain that these
ideas can represent a great
opportunity for the future of europe
thank you
let me now give the floor to manuel
aubry for
the left
president
you present yourself here today
as the champion of a europe that
protects
but who are you actually protecting
are you protecting social rights when
you empty the pockets of the unemployed
and delay the directive on platform
workers
are you protecting sovereignty
when you sign free trade agreements hand
over fist are you protecting women when
you support an anti-abortion
president of the european parliament
president
it's not enough to have the right to
abortion in the charter of fundamental
rights you need to defend that right
and
exten accept the extension of its
duration when it's discussed in france
you also shouldn't make agreements with
states such as poland who are
undermining these kinds of rights are
you protecting the planet when you allow
yourself
with
the orban's extreme right to defend gas
and nuclear it's not enough to have the
environment in the charter of
fundamental rights you've been convicted
for climate in action in france by a
french court as well
are you protecting fiscal
justice when you suck up to business
organizations on tax evasion
are you protecting the rule of law and
democracy which you mentioned many times
this morning when you make deals with
orban during your first visit as
president of france
as pres
as president of the european union and
when you disfigure yellow vest
protesters
those who you protest are certainly not
people who are struggling but
multinationals and billionaires
you announced with great fanfare a
slogan
which is recovery
strength and a sense of belonging
but in reality
your european achievements are simply
arrogance
powerlessness and plotting
on substance you're the champion of
double speak and trade-offs and on
substance you've always been the
president of contempt contempt vis-a-vis
social protection which
you believe costs shed loads of money
contempt was the vulnerable who are
nothing contempt against the unemployed
who just need to cross the road to find
a job contempt against skyvers the
illiterate and ghouls who are resistant
to change
and contempt which is now expressed
vis-a-vis your european partners and
contempt to us
given that you've decided to maintain
the french presidency of the european
union during an election campaign yes
president you're the president of
contempt but at least you've admitted it
as you said yourself you want to piss
the people off
the international
press has torn its hair out to try and
translate that
and it's just as well because you can
say it in every language to the european
people
equality vettel
just social justice shy self see climate
facility
our fundamental rights piss off
but
let's
recognize that there are people who
don't piss you off for example your
billionaire friends whose fortunes have
doubled during your five-year term as
president and that sums up the essence
of your policies president to workers to
the vulnerable activists insults and
blows to profiteers and polluters gifts
and sweet nothings colleagues let's not
let's not be fooled here
here standing in front of you today is
dr emmanuel
who had promises the earth on europe but
you also have mr macron who scraps
social rights represses demonstrations
and
doesn't care about the climate emergency
so how do you expect him to do the
opposite in europe to what he's done in
france the french presidency shouldn't
be used for electoral purposes it's a
historic opportunity
to reshuffle the pack
a founding act to start with putting
health above profits by waving patents
on covet vaccines
and that's something that you're
systematically opposed to present
so the charity that you mentioned again
today well what about that
millions of people across the world
don't have access to vaccines because
our country france and also the european
commission didn't respect the vote of
this parliament to defend waving the
patents on vaccines
another priority would be to prevent the
austerity straight jacket
being
restored it was something something
that's been turned down during the
crisis in your remote world these are
perhaps just lines on the counting
spreadsheet but in our real world these
are people these are this is social
assistance for food public services
education and health care
french said in 2005 that they didn't
want to see any more of these rules
if we because let's be clear if we want
to renationalize freight services ban
pesticides develop organic and local
canteens sanction european tax havens
etc we'll have to go against european
rules that prevent us doing that to
conclude you france is a founding member
of the european union it
has social environmental non-regression
it should have no regression clauses to
so that we don't undermine our rights
and don't slow down the fight against
climate deregulation
quoting
president general de gaulle is
fashionable at the moment
and i think what we to sum up what he
says we need to have a certain idea of
france we need to be brave
this is the french presidency of the
european union but it's being sacrificed
on the altar of your ambition but after
the french elections there'll be two
months to turn things around with
someone else in power
thank you thank you
one more reminder this is not a national
debate we are discussing the french
presidency priorities and we need to
respect this institution in that regard
next i give the floor to tatiana begin
for one minute
thank you president
president macron
we count a great deal on
your presidency now on many issues italy
and france have a common vision and i
think it's time to bring europe out of
the doldrums of paralysis selfishness
and the health and energy pandemics
pandemics that are affecting all our
citizens the five star movement would
like to present its three priorities a
minimum wage after the vote in the
european parliament negotiations with
the council have begun and we need an
ambitious agreement to increase wages in
europe fight offshoring wage dumping
and unfair competition between
businesses second point we want to see
reform of the stability and growth pact
the pandemic
has put an end to austerity hopefully
forever
green and social investments need to be
excluded
from when calculating future budgetary
constraints
thirdly the environmental and energy
transitions there's no time to waste
transport industry finance every sector
needs to make a contribution to saving
our planet from disastrous climate
change the upcoming six months will be
decisive president you have a major
responsibility be brave and ambitious
thank you
man
president macron
thank you very much madam president
i i would like to try and go back over
the main points that were raised thank
you very much
mr vapor for this appeal to action i
agree with that
first of all
let me start by thanking you for the
collective commitment that you've shown
in the fight against cancer you recalled
that there is this need to pursue this
strategy and i know how key in the
european parliament is is on that and a
number of initiatives have been taken to
that end
we've had a number of working sessions
on that during this semester
and
there are three main axes there
prevention then pediatrics and then
cancer and jobs and i'd like to thank
you because this is a topic you brought
up and it is so important
you also mentioned european sovereignty
what we've been doing for recent over
recent years is that we have uh managed
to make greater progress than in many
decades
we've had
technical projects we've had
various
projects and i could could list them
we've also made tremendous steps forward
technologically speaking
there is the
european commission's agenda on this and
we're building now this
uh technological sovereignty agenda
europe has often been thought of as just
a market and it is very important to
to accept
uh that you've got this
market and you've got these giants that
have come in to upset our
sovereignty the commission's been trying
to deal with that but we've got to put
something forward you've got to make an
offer into that market and sovereignty
if it isn't to have been purely vain
during the covert period we've seen in
fact that we've been able to
collectively buy vaccines that no member
state would have been able to do on its
own and
uh um i have uh
said to the french people that i would
not have and the french government would
have not have been able to pursue such a
vaccine strategy were not for europe and
that's
one of the elements of sovereignty we
bought then we produced then we exported
and we've been able also to donate that
is sovereignty so there are very many
concrete aspects of sovereignty and i
don't think it's something we should
beat ourselves up about
then when it comes to economic and
financial matters we've got our
sovereignty as well we've got the
european central bank which is decided
very quickly
politically
to voluntarily provide financing and the
base on the basis of that starting in
july
with a debate in parliament we've
launched this
whole debate on sovereignty and we've
decided to go with macroeconomic and
investment choices to help relaunch the
europe economy and i think this is
something that has been done we have
acted we need to go go further
you also mr vapor mentioned russia and i
quite agree
that we have to act and as you know
france itself tried to relaunch an
active dialogue
and then with chancellor merkel a few
months ago we were pushing for a
resumption of
european dialogue with russia
unfortunately we weren't supported in
that by our colleagues and we're going
to get back to work on that it's been
very difficult after all to have a
sovereignty policy uh with or vis-a-vis
russia if you're not talking to russia
so we've got these sanctions in place
since 2014 but that's not enough on its
own we've got a fairly complete agenda
and i've been trying to dissent that out
with all these initiatives about how
we're going to build this new stability
uh order
now as i've said we're going to have to
construct the conditions for sovereignty
that's to say
more independence visa v russia and if
we look at our oil and gas input we're
not we're not independent visa v russia
we're not going to become that overnight
we have a lot to win with russia but we
mustn't find ourselves in such a
vulnerable position in the future and
that is a debate that we have to conduct
and in the light of that it is quite
clear that climate strategy is going to
be important i'll come back to that but
i agree i think the solution that i've
got in my mind is that in the coming
weeks we'll come up with a concrete
european proposal now on rights and
values i quite agree with what you say
and i'm just going to try and decon
structure with that we've got
conditionality um and uh many of you
referred to that
the european parliament quite rightly
stuck up for the european union's budget
uh um
given that there were attacks on
european union finances
then the european court of justice ruled
and if we're going to validate that that
we're going to have to get the
commission involved and the commission
set
the terms for that
uh what we now have proposed and voted
then we've got the procedures based on
article seven of the treaty
and the procedure is moving on
thanks to
the successive presidencies of council
we've got
it set for
poland in february and hungary in march
and so
i i think like you do that it's all
moving too slowly but i do think that
it's in our interest to try and convince
and modify things as indeed the european
commission has been trying to do in
recent weeks with poland because i don't
think that the uh response to the rule
of law problems is for europe to draw
back
i
think for some countries to leave
the common uh
undertaking because they don't respect
the rules that's not a nice answer
either so things are taking too long and
i'm quite sure we're going to have to
have stronger
harder hitting measures as part of our
reforms and at the same time we're going
to have to continue our work to to
bring round people's minds to this now
when we're talking about rule of law
there is uh effectiveness in moving
ahead together and
a lot of this is before the court so
there's significant financing at states
a million euro fine against poland uh
daily at the moment for not having
implemented a
a a european court of justice ruling and
the commissioners the guardian of the
treaties uh must not allow in the face
of that ruling these uh attacks on our
sovereignty to pres to to to persist so
there are consequences now on climate
transition you were talking about unity
and
i'll come back to that transition it's
it is important i agree with you
and
what
president jacob was saying a moment ago
i i would also agree with part of that
there are different accompanying
measures which are on the table at the
moment
amidst the european institutions i'm
just trying to recall that because
that's a context we find ourselves as
the fair transition fund set up in 21 to
help the regions
with high carbon intensity levels to
transition
uh 17 billion euros
through to 2027 then there's the
recovery plan for europe we've got the
uh
recovery and resilience facility and
helping helping to fight climate change
with real measures and then we've got
what we're doing in each of our own
countries and france has uh uh done its
its bit to do that then there's the uh
social fund for the climate which has
been set up uh also all with the same
intent
and i would put this before you as proof
that things are moving forward
i agree with you that we we need to move
ahead together
ms garcia perez on the rule of law
i was just answering the the questions
on that but let me just add one thing
it's important here just as it is in
france there has never been
any choice made by france certainly to
get rid of the european flag let me just
uh remind you that there are facts
at play here but there was a celebration
and we had the european flag hanging
beside the french flag and that's as i
explained to my fellow citizens um
um
there is no flag on the 1st of january
and
so um as the 31st of december as in on
many other monuments we decided to
fly the
european flag alone
and the french one was removed for that
purpose there's nothing there's no
polemic there it's just uh this european
uh intention
substituting one flag for another yes
um when you get a european flag hanging
in those uh flying in those
circumstances i am proud of it
when it comes to our social action and
the agenda that you were reminding us of
us of i'd like to thank you
and i'd like to just say
that
all of that agenda is important we've
got the minimum wage directive
okay there's a huge amount of work
that's gone into that and i'd like to
thank the member states who wanted to
move ahead they were the most ambitious
socially but there was a social dialogue
transition in those states which meant
that this rather constraining european
approach needed to be clarified and
sorted out so we've got this directive
on the minimum wage which is pursuing
two main objectives first of all
the collective agreement for minimum
wage uh which is a tradition and when
those traditions exist and you have
criteria relating to the setting of that
minimum wage
now it we are i think true to our role
in the european union by respecting the
powers and the specificities and
competencies of all of our member states
but try and get social convergence from
the
top uh respecting at the same time all
the different models and i think with
that in mind we should be able this
semester to move forward very much in
the spirit that you were evoking on
platforms i think uh you you you you
mentioned meadowmoby as well uh
i agree with the philosophy there i
don't wish to ban innovation and i'm not
in favor of just letting fair but we
have to have um
the law in place to manage it so we've
got texts in in in the law in france
which is uh going through to regulation
and we have to protect workers
throughout europe workers working on
platforms in europe um so protecting
them is not the same as banning the
platforms because these are jobs that go
with the platforms and i think there is
a social utility so we need to create
these jobs we need to
circumscribe them and i think protecting
them is important then there were
decisions uh made by the
european commission there were proposals
made by the european commission and we
have to consolidate social rights for
all workers trying to level up
that is something that we've seen at a
national level uh this is something that
uh has come from the european commission
we're hoping that it will progress
we will move ahead with ambition on that
because it does provide for a high level
of protection
now you reminded us
and after your madam president and many
others did mention the importance of the
equality between men and women issue and
in your words you stress that i i would
just like to endorse how indeed at the
heart of our
semester this is going to have a number
of important texts accompanying it
when it comes to a better
balance in company boards
we
have a new coalition in germany and we
do work with them to move the text
forward and i do hope now we'll be able
to pick up some speed when it comes to
the fairness of um
remuneration and gaps that exist between
male and female
wages we've got this directive on
celerial transparency and the principle
of equality um of remuneration for work
of equal value is very much underpinning
that then there's uh the prevention
um against um the prevention of violence
against women
and we've got the instant bull
convention as well which is very
important and there have been a number
of member states slightly dragging their
feet so those are a few points of
clarification i wish to wish to make
one thing that was mentioned
on number of occasions is that we hold
these speeches yes words
words are what we use we've not found a
better solution for the time being but
they are followed by acts and by texts
which are in the pipeline they're the
fruit of our common labors and that's
something i've just been saying uh will
apply to
this semester
mr schizoid thank you very much for what
you were saying about europe of youth
and young people the european civic
project
i think is important we're about to
celebrate the erasmus anniversary and
the choice that has been made
collectively and that you voted for i
think would increase the budget
significantly extending
the asbestos program to young apprentice
apprentices and allowing us to
really move the bar on that
this this
pact as well i'm very favorable to that
it's got very specific consequences uh
which everybody is aware of and this is
something that we will support and hope
to get um and underpinned in council
getting a signature by all member states
and all the institutions involved
mr jedu
ah yes you were talking
about um
being a president
you you're speaking from your heart you
were
talking as a president of a group
passionately and uh
let me now just come back over a few
points um
on the taxonomy of things first of all
that's very important and a choice has
been made
for different energy sources
some of you picked up on this and i'm
somewhat surprised that there are any
criticisms being made of text being
signed on subjects of a social
environmental or energy energy character
with countries like poland and hungary
what do we do just put the european
union on hold no we enter into a
dialogue when we don't agree and we step
up to the plate and when it comes to
disagreements on principles that we hold
dear with various countries we try and
move forward we shouldn't hold up the
rest of the agenda this is how europe
works otherwise europe is completely
blocked because tomorrow
one of your colleagues might say
well we don't agree with you at all
about the climate which is the most
important thing you don't deserve to be
at the table we're talking about
equality men and women or rule of law no
that doesn't work no you see that's the
way europe works and it gives us the
possibility to move forward and progress
next
and i'm being very sincere here we don't
have a gas agenda in france
our history and our electric mix means
that we don't need that but
looking at the scientific reality and
you were talking about precisely that we
don't technologically speaking have the
possibility now to take
intermittent forms and make them
non-intermittent forms of generation of
electricity otherwise we would make our
supply
we would
we would undermine the security supply
of energy of electricity for our
citizens so we've got coal gas nuclear
and then we've got the renewables and
we're going to have to continue to
develop them and go much further with
them and the day when we've got
storage facility or storage technology
available we don't have at the moment
and all the international um experts
have classified
um
these sources of energy as
non-intermittent ones
so
we've got the science behind this and i
don't really think that the science
could be challenged
the most polluting source of energy is
carbon and many countries still use is
sorry it's cold but many countries still
use them
and uh and then gas so trying to get out
of
coal moving towards france is helpful
that's not the case for france but it's
useful and we're going to have to hold
the hands of those countries that are
moving from coal to gas now when it
comes to nuclear and others have got
this as a plank in their strategy
we've got to recognize that
nuclear energy is a non-carbon energy
and that's a scientific reality and
that's why i think the commission texts
on this is a good text because it's
based upon science and i would add that
it's not just a matter of
uh
allowing europe to
realize its transition strategy
it's perfectly coherent with the
sovereignty project because
we produce nuclear energy on our
territory and gas we
pretty much don't produce any more in
our territory
that's a reality and so this is in a
context in which we're trying to
electrify mobility we're going to
produce hydrogen and
whilst trying to bring down our
traditional forms of consumption
was at the same time seeing an increase
in the use of electricity which means
that we've got to have base load
non-intermittent sources of energy and i
think therefore defending this uh text
on
nuclear et cetera is is actually very
much in line with protecting the
environment and defending
um or pledging against climate change
now you were sort of laying down the law
somewhat
on one point
but let's be very careful
mobility yes
certainly back in 2018
when um
france produced a very um far-reaching
policy on glyphosate um but you're you
you were partly responsible in power at
the time and things didn't move forward
so i'm now grateful that uh
we've managed to achieve this uh
agreement on carbon neutron to the end
of last year where we've got uh
different political forces i think um
political groups including yours that
were present and france
very much was leading the way on that
strategy and you cannot
deny that
whether it's the green deal whether it's
carbon unity by 2050 or banning united
states we've been there and
we've even been criticized having
gone it alone being too isolated but
this is not this is not a spirit and i'm
just going to say this to madame obrie
as well it's not a question of
compromising it's exactly what happens
here it's finding compromises to get
useful european solutions but we're not
alone
we are very ambitious and i'd also like
to say the extent to which we were the
leaders for trade uh deals france was
the country that was most opposed to the
signing of new trade agreements and
opposed mercosur because of the lack of
upholding of the paris uh
agreements and uh
what we said well there were two things
first of all that it must be thought of
of europe not signing anything which
doesn't abide by the paris accords
secondly miracles is whenever this
happens so
we also uh supported the border carbon
tax this is a practical tax
and i ultimately agree with the ambition
that you were setting out
but we all have to find a place
where
we've got these very specific proposals
we've got these very realistic
requirements and this is what we've been
trying to do in france and and i'm not
going to back over that because this
isn't the time of the place but whether
it's
renewing power stations or insulating
houses whatever it might be we're trying
to go faster it's just that
you've got to do it in the real world
and it's exactly the same thing in
europe and we will press ahead on it
when it comes to
investment clauses with china i'm just
going to pick up on this because well
there are three things first of all we
signed with uh chancellor merkel and the
institutions in 2020 an agreement that
was very clear setting up principles
whereby
the objective was first of all to
protect all all of the totality of our
industrial sectors and their
intellectual property rather than
leaving it anonymous secondly we said
clear conditions when it comes to
[Music]
the directives
for international labour agreements so
that some of the practices you were
mentioned forced labor the massacre of
vegas etc could be stopped and
really now the ball is in the chinese
court and these are discussions which
have been
stopped for the moment and we're waiting
for the bull to be returned from the
chinese court and we're waiting for the
dialogue to resume so that sanctions can
be lifted and a number of members of
this house have spoken exactly on that
topic saying that they have these
sanctions imposed on china and
it is necessary for the dialogue to
resume for them to be
lifted now you mentioned and i'm
grateful to you for having put this in
such clear terms the humanism the
humanity that is behind all of these
issues of migration and that the people
that um
that are migrants are in great misery
and
you you express this with tremendous
emotion expressing the great
seriousness the situation we find
ourselves in in canada
france
and that from the start of the mandate
my mandate
has faced up to the humanitarian mandate
because what we are faced with here are
people who are trying to
join their loved ones in france sorry in
the uk
and we've built um centers
to help
process to feed
um and to try and make sure that
applications put in can be heeded
but the situation is that almost every
week hundreds of men and women who have
across europe asia minor parts of africa
find themselves in these these reception
centers and we cannot
make as if this is a sustainable
situation because these are people
living on french soil in calais
sometimes finding themselves in great
need in celebrity and in security and we
are trying to improve the situation uh
there have been sanctions placed against
france but we we have sincerely tried to
bring all the forces to bear
it might be
interior security or health services try
to bring them to bear but ultimately we
cannot solve that problem if the way in
which migratory flows are seen from the
british side
doesn't change
our british friends at the moment
are
trying to adopt an approach which is the
one that
prevailed at the start of the 80s where
you've got
a level of acceptable economic illegal
migration uh you will allow people to
work without papers because it's it's
helpful with the economy but that isn't
uh that doesn't face the reality of
migratory flows now secondly
there need to be legal stable
routes to be able to migrate to the uk
and this is the situation that we're
confronted with this is uh this is a
dialogue that we need to pursue with the
uk in it's it's a
horrendous
humanitarian situation but that's that's
the reality
mr pardella
you said that the french people
were sad i really unhappy i really don't
think that's the case
then
you stood here and many other speakers
did and
[Music]
what you did here
was deliver a pretty f franco-french
speech
but
you went through it
saying pretty much anything you that
came into your head about any of the
european texts so well done
and
the methodical approach that you did
that and deserve some respect because it
really shows a sort of um coherence if
you like it sorry it bro it brought to
light the incoherence of what you were
saying but
so you
you said that we'd signed a text which
removed
state sovereignty when it came to
migration but we're sitting around table
in council
i see the president of the epp groups
they're saying we're too slow
but with discussion migratory pact there
um
is it under the famous secret pact no
so these are areas where we still have
some national competence and this is
precisely why
we
try to
provide a re-launch for the schengen
project and the commissioners produced
far has produced powerful uh proposals
what we might do to protect the borders
of shang and to give schengen and to
give more impetus
to it
strengthening our external borders
improving
cooperation improving cooperation and
trying to coordinate
the return
at a central level to the countries of
origin so i think what
the tenets of what you said are just not
right we're confronted by a migratory
pressure at the moment there are a
number of fundamental different reasons
for that and we have to try and set
about working through them uh
methodologically speaking as we're doing
with africa at the moment but we still
need to protect our external borders we
have to fight against the inefficiencies
of a common approach which tends to lead
to rather absurd policies between member
states from time to time and then we
need to make sure that people can be
returned to their countries of origin on
a common basis which isn't working at
the moment so i think that's what i
would say about that i think i've
covered the other topics
mr
legetko
mr fito
you were talking about the rule of law
i think i've covered most of the other
topics but
you
mentioned the growth pact let me just
say two words about that
during this crisis in europe we've had a
very
effective and pragmatic approach
learning from the past and we've
suspended
the classic rules in order that we might
act and we've given ourselves the first
time on our history this
recovery plan which has allowed us to
provide massive investment
in the european level so the question
then is
how do we get back to normality now
we're not going to see the same
normalities we have before the crisis we
are going to have to tackle
macroeconomic issues in the light of the
reconstruction of our european
independence firstly and we're going to
have to do that in the light of making
necessary investments we've talked about
the investment in the climate which is
going to be absolutely massive we're
going to have some national one some
european ones then we've got the
technology agenda as well and the
digital agenda and the social agenda
which will accompany those and then the
geopolitical requirements
will need us to invest and that's
just the start of the list this shows
how we are
this is the logic of our new investment
strategy and we will have to have a
strategic strategy
sorry strategic discussion in march
where we look at how we can bring to bed
the budgetary
responsibilities and other
responsibilities
this is common money after all and then
we're all going to have to be ambitious
in our investment policy otherwise we
are going to be left behind by american
and chinese powers which are increasing
their investments in many areas and if
we want a proper space strategy if we
want a proper semiconductor strategy or
artificial intelligence
uh quantum quantum computing and the
list goes on then we're going to have to
have that kind of an investment
policy
you mentioned uh
free ex
free trade madam
you then went on to say something very
true
the french
presidency of the european union must be
a stepping stone
um
you're right
[Applause]
mustn't be an electoral stepping stone
and so you're right
i'm not doing it
the final topic
that you mentioned
more important still
affecting people's lives
is this question of the vaccines and i
wish to defend our europe
all of us and the commission first of
all because we are the only
area
in the world which has bought and then
very rapidly produce more than two
billion doses to date and has never
had any export ban and we produce more
almost two and a half billion doses
we've exported half of them no other
area in the world has done that the us
for months and months in the crisis
banned exports and the component parts
and also to emergent and developing
countries that weren't able to produce
for themselves or for others that's a
reality and we're going to have to be um
when we say that europe is a strong and
responsible model then we have to step
up to the plate that's the reality we've
done it we've always exported 50 since
from the very start we initiated
solidarity
measures so it was a
a an initiative of europe and and africa
the actor initiative which led to this
um vaccinating a dialogue and policy and
as of
april 2020 and i myself was in the
african union bureau meeting at the time
and was able to convince all the members
of the g20 to press ahead with it
so
the short-term priority has been
donating doses and i mentioned uh what
we were doing on that we've already
we had already provided 100 million
doses whereas uh
china have done 60 million these are
realities that we shouldn't forget
there's this geopolitical competition
and we shouldn't allow ourselves
to
find ourselves on the back foot
the second element is that we said we
need to have an agenda on this a
timetable and we got one straight away
in order to assist africans with
producing vaccines but let me say here
clearly that today's
vaccinations
can't be carried out by producing
vaccines now if you start producing
vaccines in africa now you'll have
vaccines available in 18 months or two
years time you won't have vaccines
straight away so the priority for the
vaccine that we've only had for a year
was to
ensure that we donated doses to africa
to ensure that they arrived and could be
jabbed into arms now what we also need
to do is improve our work with unicef
because on the ground we've seen certain
policies fail because of deorganized
disorganization so this is something
that we really have to
work on and the second point is that we
shouldn't
forget
our support for primary health systems
african countries don't often have the
money sometimes have the money for
primary health systems and if they can't
fund their primary health systems it's
very difficult for them to vaccinate
people
we've provided bilateral assistance on
vaccinations
but uh we can't
let that
take pre take precedence over local
health systems they can't be left behind
in addition
africa comprises 20 percent of vaccine
needs in the world and they produce 2
percent of global vaccines so every time
there's a health crisis in the world a
new wave or another crisis
pressure will arrive because national
and regional selfishness will reassert
itself so our agenda
needs to
produce vaccines on the african country
continent and in all the poorest and
emerging countries last spring for
example i went to rwanda and to south
africa and that's where we launched our
projects on vaccines and there's a
debate
on intellectual property here and
waving patterns
now on this let me be clear
france was in favor of this but it's
easy for france to be in favor because
we don't have any patterns today because
it wasn't french pharmaceutical
companies that found the vaccine so we
have no patterns i'm being honest here
but i'm not but that's you know i can
only do that i can't be cynical here as
french president
some of our neighbors
who helped us to
vaccinate our people who have the
patents on these
but should we rip up
intellectual property rights well no i
don't think we should because that is
the appropriate reward for research
men and women are behind these new
vaccines they need to be rewarded but
what we do need to do
is ensure that
intellectual property and patents
never become
something that undermines production and
it isn't at the moment so yes this is an
ideological political debate a worthy
debate and uh i'm happy to tell you what
i think about it but it's not
something
that is appropriate because firstly you
have to
transfer the technology and create the
capacity
we currently
don't
in
france
have the capacity to produce these for
example
and we're not blocked when it comes to
intellectual property rights
we just want to transfer the technology
to the african continent that's
what's important to us so these debates
are important
they're political debates in the noble
sense of the term
but
we shouldn't move away from what's
practical because we have to move
forward when it comes to helping africa
so the priority is to finance
those structures that produce vaccines
we need to create partnerships and
transfer technology and that's where
europeans together with the world health
organization
and by putting pressure
on
large pharmaceutical companies need to
be more present we need to speed up this
transfer of technology
to ensure that those who have the
knowledge delegate teams to start
production in africa
so europe is the continent that has done
most on this by far the european
commission has several times been to
africa to develop african capacities in
senegal rwanda canada south africa etc
we'll continue doing that
the
proposal that i hope we'll be able to
make
as europeans and which we'll be working
towards during the coming weeks
will
be a joint african european one
and the idea
would be
as the director general of the wto
proposes together with the director
general of the who
the idea is to ensure that every time we
create these capacities we lift
all restrictions in terms of capacity
intellectual property and technology
transfer so that we can ensure
that
capacities can be developed
in africa
so by the end of february
what we're hoping to do is have a joint
proposal that we can bring to the eu
africa summit eu african union summit on
cove vaccine covered vaccines and other
vaccines
and hopefully we'll have an agenda
to defend president i think i've
responded
to the questions that you asked me as
well because you asked on the growth
model and on our values and i think i've
been pretty exhausted in what i've said
thank you
merci
merced
thank you mr president for those replies
now we begin with back bench speakers
and the first is francois xavier bellamy
from the epp group for two minutes
please
i'm so i will be strict
mr president of the republic
you've made big promises sir but not
many of us here really believe them not
just because the timetable that you put
forward looks more like it's geared to
your presidential campaign than the eu
presidency but also because you've
contradicted yourself
you've played around with the meaning of
very important word so much
that you have to be quite honest sir
lied
you say you want to get control of the
borders of europe but yesterday you were
saying nationalist leprosy
for was being used by those countries
who wanted to protect their borders you
talked about this strategic economy but
france is importing coal and
gas because you've undermined our
domestic industries
you've
said that the roots of europe are
crucially important
but where is the sap which is going to
nourish this these roots in the future
europe is more divided and broken than
ever
we're aware
that your words are just
there to disguise the inconsistency of
your policies deliberate inconsistency
europe and its realities have become a
huge
contradiction and that is embodied in
yourself mr president and we are the
people who have to sort it out our group
our delegation will do all it can to
make these six months as good as
possible for the countries of europe but
that's not the issue anymore the issue
is to say to everybody in france in
europe who is watching that another kind
of policy is possible a policy which
takes people seriously which
makes
action more important than slogans and
doesn't weaken europe will doesn't
believe that european solidarity is
getting into excessive debt that
wants to trample people's liberties and
freedoms under foot in the name of
respecting the rule of law that respects
the people of europe and gets europe
respected by the major powers of the
world
if you're just going to achieve that
that'll be a lot
and we will be able to work together
with you to do that and we need to help
you because you're not going to do it
yourself
you mr bellamy
our next speaker is silvigeon for two
minutes
colleagues
president of france
there
is no ambiguity here when it comes to
your national position but here you're
speaking as president of the european
council rather than the french president
and because we're demanding we want to
see france make a positive contribution
to the european project
now thinking about italy
our former president david sasoli and
the french presidency programme
i think
we can see that the good the bad and the
rest is there now the good things are
useful for europeans border
carbon adjustment taxed uh digital uh
progress etc social democrats many of
these things we agree with and we'll be
watching carefully to
ensure that these things are implemented
but there's also a more brutal tougher
face inequalities
poverty
the homeless
tax avoidance tax evasion
instrumentalizing schengen and migration
there's
all that is either not in there or
should be in there and then there is a
whole series of things
that uh the french presidency simply
wants to ignore uh climate ambitions for
example the taxonomy or the principle of
energy efficiency economic governance
and budget rules
or the where the ambitions for major
reform have disappeared and when it
comes to the rule of law
we understand that you're not going to
criticize your colleagues in the council
so we think and also the uh conference
on the future of europe which uh risks
becoming nothing like many similar
initiatives now it's really good to try
and do everything at the same time
and uh you're trying to impose a sort of
france plus vision on europe
europe can't be decreed it needs to be
built by respecting our assembly as well
thank you
dear mr president dear colleagues
the pagasa spying scandal is the
european watergate and mr president you
understand this more than anyone else in
this chamber because you yourself
were also targeted with the pagaza
software
so i call for your solidarity with the
journalists lawyers and politicians in
poland and hungary who were spied on by
their own governments
most targets in hungary have one thing
in common they were all critics of the
urban government
clearly this is their way to intimidate
all of us who still dare to defy them
so
mr president this should never happen in
europe we have to acknowledge that
and we ask the french presidency to
finally address democratic backsliding
and to address the pegasus spying
scandal in the article 7 proceedings
because if governments in europe can
continue to use secret service weapons
against political opponents to go
through family pictures to listen into
private conversations without any
consequences then we cannot speak of
democracies anymore and thus the very
foundation of the european union will
fall apart the eu has to take action and
the french presidency now has the chance
to do so mr president we are counting
thank you very much i give the floor
next to jordy soleil for one minute
[Applause]
mr president
there are various different ways to make
the eu stronger one is to demonstrate
full respect for diversity
we mustn't be frightened of diversity
neither must we distrust democracy since
these
are the two traits that characterize us
but diversity in particular linguistic
diversity is having a hard time in
europe
in catalonia the spanish courts are
trying to
end the educational model that has
allowed students to master both catalan
and spanish
in france languages such as oxytocin
breton alsatian basque and catalan are
still considered to be second-class
languages be courageous and ensure that
these languages acquire the rights and
resources that they deserve and as was
initially the intention of the molag law
mr president
uh we talked about
the promise of european democracy and we
hope too that the european union
will want to uphold the democratic
rights of all peoples to be freezed to
choose their best future and thus take
up their rightful place in this union
nuclear bay for two minutes
thank you madam president mr president
of the republic
i remember september 2017 your speech at
the saw bomb the expression of a certain
kind of european ambition which has your
term of officers gone on has become more
and more empty more and more arrogant
now we're on the threshold of a new
election you're a president but of
course you're particularly in particular
a candidate and you're using the
presidency of the french president the
european union as a marketing
opportunity not as a chance to improve
nations and people's lives because your
form has been marked by failures
failures as far as posted workers are
concerned where there's still unfair
competition with countries in eastern
europe a failure to get europe and
france respected when erdogan provokes
humiliates and threatens we still
continue to spend and pay
billions of euros to turkey with such
more and more like extortion and wants
and we're now going to renew the customs
union as well failure as far as the
nuclear issue is concerned which you
basically abandoned for four years and
have recently rediscovered but your own
commissioner czech return said that
we're only going to
replace
nuclear will replace 15 of electricity
as opposed to 26 today
to fader as far as the recovery plan is
concerned as well
france is also lagging behind europe as
far as our borders are concerned only
one illegal immigrant intent is expelled
do you really think you can do in three
weeks what you've failed or three months
to do what you fail to do in five years
and also it's not really your program
it's the commission's program and it's
that which the people of france and the
peoples of europe as a whole will be
aware of
we're not doing enough as far as our
external borders are concerned we're not
putting forward europe as a culture or
product we're not putting forward europe
as a power
which persuades rather than threatens
we're not having france's voice heard
you said you were going to make france's
voice heard but in fact you're trembling
along the old rails laid down by the
brussels technocracy it already looks
like you've missed the boat as far as
your presidency is concerned sir five
minutes
thank you well congratulations president
macron you've managed to persuade many
millions of europeans
that
the europe that they want
is the opposite of yours the europe
of arrogance
and bullying that has now reached the
european parliament
which abuses its speaking time to
campaign for the french presidency in
the european parliament as you did in
your unprecedented 39 minute long
response to the questions
europe is in a dramatic situation there
is an explicit military threat
in to the east of the european union
and we have poland
under direct threat together with the
ukraine and you can't defend our borders
you can't defend poland
you come here and you say that everyone
is to blame poland and hungary are to
blame as you say
whereas you're applying measures under
the pretext of kovid that seem chinese
in nature
and then
the violence that you exercise against
the yellow vests and demonstrators
that's also chinese these are violations
of the rule of law
these are tools that you're using in
your ideological war against
hungary and poland your presence here is
unprecedented you haven't said anything
about birth rate issues about families
the massive economic problems that
families are facing as a result of the
pandemic
it seems that the speaker is interrupted
go ahead
thank you madam president mr president
candidate
you
just criticized some for using this
debate for electoral purposes was that a
bad faith
you are trying to keep to the calendar
of the french presidency
um having uh
it as a place upon which your your
ambitions for france are being
sacrificed and you presented yourself
this morning as the candidate for
industrial sovereignty uh
for all of the different foundries and
uh
in fact what's happened is that you're
the president of uh industrial decline
you said you were in favor of of of um
climate protection but you've been
condemned in the french and european
courts for climate inaction and
environmental inaction you've presented
yourself as winning as the candidate
candidate for the rule of law the
defense of freedoms
nonsense you are the president that this
parliament itself has uh said has been
responsible for the uh disastrous
shilijon movement
so you've not lived up to your own good
promises and
in a few months time the french will be
able to
make their vote
i give the floor next to miss lafkala
kusich for one minute
dear madam president dear colleagues
dear citizens of the european union
president macron
considering
the many limitations to
human rights and citizens rights during
fraud during the pandemic in france i
ask you only one thing and that is that
during your presidency you do the exact
opposite of what you did in france on
the other hand
you said today that
you're proud of the fact that in europe
there is no death sentence tens of
thousands of citizens died
due to the consequences of vaccination
mandatory vaccination is a death
sentence and at the same time the
execution of a death sentence to many
citizens
this must be the free choice of all
citizens murder is murder those of you
who don't know
and you are not informed you can read
the
who pages thank
you down from parliament
thank you president
president macron vice president uh
colleagues
all the best for the french council
presidency
president you spoke of freedom as a
european promise
freedom is the greatest achievement
of
our european union as is peace and we
need to ensure that we're a reliable
partner in the world for that there are
problems however we have no european
response
to russian aggression on the borders of
ukraine
i think that one of the most important
tasks of your presidency
will be to ensure that the 27 member
states stick together
when it comes to russia member states
need to agree on one way of acting
because it's only then that we will
be respected in the
world otherwise we'll shamefully see
that russia and the united states decide
on european
security architecture and our future and
our second
issue is sustainability you said that
that was going to be a focus of your
presidency now for me
that
means not living at the co at the cost
of future
generations and that goes for financial
matters as well we can't leave debts
behind for future generations france has
a state debt of 115 percent one of the
highest in the eurozone in the european
union and the european and the euro zone
we need to have solid sustainable
budgets i was in favor
of relaxing our debt rules but we
shouldn't be living at the expense of
our future generations thank you
[Applause]
thank you madam president we've learned
that europe becomes credible in the eyes
of its citizens if it changes people's
lives for the better and it needs to
have tools in order to do that in the
dark years of the pandemic europe did
produce instruments even inventing new
ones that weren't thought of before
the way it's been distributing vaccines
which you mentioned yourself mr
president and also the idea of the next
generation eu but that's not enough of
course we need to look very carefully at
the six months of the french presidency
because the work which has been carried
out up till now needs to continue we've
given hope to
companies who are trying to escape from
the emergency but we need also not just
to continue doing that but also to build
further
we need to reform the civility account
bring in changes to the tax system and
make certain the next general the next
generation eu is part and parcel of
europe put an end to austerity even
though some people in council want to do
that means putting a break on growth
which is more sustainable in
environmental terms and more fair in
social terms that's not the kind of
europe that you mentioned thank you
next is luis garricano for one minute
as you said europe rules you argued with
mr draghi very persuasively in the
financial times the existing rules are
neither credible nor nor
counter-cyclical
moreover as you just argued the new
rules must allow for increasing
investment in climate so we need to to
invest in additional one percent of our
gdp
to fight climate change how to do it
my proposal is to sidestep the existing
system and build a parallel one
after all as the german fines mr mr
lingard said recently the existing rules
have shown that they can be flexible an
opinion by the commission could entrench
that flexibility so the new system would
have two pillars
the first would be a climate investment
fund
that would provide new loans and grants
to member states that comply with a new
counter-cyclical expenditure rule
the second pillar would be new european
independent fiscal agency that would
ensure that only countries that have
that comply with that independent fiscal
with those counter-cyclical expenditure
rules have access to the fund mr
president as you can see this is
inspired by our historic recovery in
resilience facility which we approved
last year and i hope we can make history
thank you very much lewis i give the
floor next to vice president haltela for
one minute
congratulations now
in 2017
something happened
paris
put businesses on the path to
sustainability and the law on that was
an important step
now it is time to establish those rules
at the european level to ensure
businesses are sustainably managed as
are their supply chains investors are
looking for clear and transparent rules
on sustainability of businesses as well
so we need a systemic change here
is paris ready to
produce a brussels effect now after the
paris effect
on the sustainability of businesses will
the french presidency make rapid
progress
on
the
it file on the governance of sustainable
businesses thank you
for one minute
president
president
president um
president macron
now we know one of the main aims of the
french president should be but it's
clear that progress on growth can only
be achieved if we have accessible and
payable energy provision that's a
crucial point
so we have to welcome
clearly the fact that you president
macron unlike other heads of government
actually are facing reality
and recognize modern nuclear energy
climate change at the same time a good
standard of living can only be achieved
with modern reactors
it's a question of reason and we
expressly welcome that
but
there is quite a lot of lack of reason
behind another of your points you want
to bring about growth in the form of
joint loans and extend competition rules
and actually maybe
completely get rid of them that's not
acceptable and it's crazy in
macroeconomic terms with such plans you
will not be creating progress or growth
but you will rather be leading the eu
into a further financial crisis which
should be avoided
madam president
mr president ladies and gentlemen
europe is facing many challenges we are
now
going through
multiple crises and the french
presidency will definitely not have a
easy time ahead of it but
we
are hopeful about this we do hope that
we will be able to tackle all these
crises
having in mind the good of the europeans
we should define our priorities first of
all we should say what is most important
for us mr president has presented to us
a very ambitious program of the
presidency however
it seems to me that what we should do
first and foremost is to
define the key
points we will be referring to in our
debate and that we will be searching
unity about europe today needs unity
europe needs stabilization
and good solutions
a debate and not
mutual accusations or attempts at
discrediting a certain country or a
political group only because it holds
different views from all the others from
the majority present in this room this
is the time of unity in
europe it's very difficult to build
unity
in diversity but this is the strength of
europe this is how it was formed there
is nothing more important than
energy crisis the poverty among
europeans and the security of europeans
these are real challenges this is
um the life of europeans today in our
countries that is why we should focus
first and foremost on this we should
help them tackle those problems i do
hope that the french presidency will go
in that direction however
to end my speech i need to say something
about the rule of law
every time you challenge the rule of law
in poland i need to speak as a former
prime minister who had the opportunity
to talk about this also with the
president macron poland is a country
of rule of law
so the voices coming from budapest or
warsaw are exactly as valuable as the
ones coming from other
for one minute
a few
modest comments if i may mr president
in light of what you've said first of
all double standards we should give up
double standards and give up political
blackmailing double standards and this
kind of blackmail is not honest it is
also contrary to the rule of law and
it's very much detrimental to our
european values
furthermore i would say that you can't
take political mileage out of everything
make everything into an issue of
ideology in addition to that it is
contrary to our european fundamental
values
you may be talking about liberal
democracy and yet that is not what it's
about
also
i don't think it's a question of
ideology but a question of technology
when we address questions of energy what
kind of energy is green what kind of
energy is not green i think that without
nuclear power it will be impossible for
us to meet our ambitious objectives in
our energy policy area and finally our
outside borders we need to defend our
external borders you can't let everyone
in you can't put pressure on others
pressuring them into making the same
mistakes as you have made when it comes
to illegal migration done for one and a
half minutes
your excellency um
the french president your excellencies
uh let me say first and foremost that
romania owes a lot to france from the
19th century from edgar finney and jules
michele who were friends of romania and
supporters remember to napoleon iii
without whom we would have had no
dynasty without france
the modernization of our country would
have
taken longer and we thank you for this
henry bertlock called romania's family
and reorganized romanian army which
helped us uh protect not only our
territory but our national identity over
the past 20 years
france
has always stood by us regarding eu
accession thank you for your support mr
president
once again you play an important part
for us
and you carry on the tradition of
friendship and you
become
our advocate in terms of the accession
to the schengen area since 2011 we have
met all the accession criteria but our
accession to the schengen area is
politically blocked we are kept at the
door unfortunately this unfair situation
towards us
uh gives rise to extremism in my country
last year romania was the exception a
positive exception we didn't have any um
political parties hostile to the eu but
the tables f10 now
and uh what is happening now fuels uh
anti-western uh uh
opinions we are now becoming a breeding
ground to anti-semitism in the far right
we uh romanians ask for your help and
are counting on you because as history
um the
madam president interrupts the speaker
now i give the floor to alexa josa libo
president president madam president
president macron
19 pandemic it is vital to continue
financing the recovery and address the
social and employment related challenges
resulting from the pandemic and support
our workers our businesses in the move
towards a more solidarity-based digital
greener and climate-neutral economy i
welcome the presidency's program but i
wish to see more priorities driven by a
reinforced commitment to promoting
sustainable growth and policy actions
that deliver for people and for our
workers that build stronger european
institutions based on solidarity and
social progress i am happy with the
presidency's focus on social inclusion
of vulnerable people such as persons
with disability still more concrete
commitments are needed to unblock the
current anti-discrimination directive i
also welcome the presidency's priorities
when it comes to employment and
digitalization but was disappointed not
to see anything on teleworking and on
the right to disconnect last but not
least i hope that after 10 years we can
deliver european
thank you next i give the flow to ilhan
cuck for one minute
thank you thank you madam president
it perfectly describes the needs of the
today's european union
facing the health crisis the rise of
aggressive powers and climate disruption
a europe that relies on unity to lead
through these difficult times
you mentioned a lot of priorities but i
want to focus only on three
building a genuine european sovereignty
and strategic autonomy
if we don't go forward with that or
europe will always be blamed to be too
little too late
second engaging with western balkans and
eastern partnership countries
mr president engaging with western
balkans is the best investment in
securities values in european interests
countries from western balkans are
historically and geographically part of
the europe
and they deserve to be part of today's
european union and thirdly conference on
the future of europe
it is not a listening exercise
it is a project that can lead and renew
european union for better we need more
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much mr kuchuk next is rasmus
andresen for one minute
your council presidency unfortunately
got off to a bad start
you've been lobbying for the french
nuclear industry and therefore there is
a a threat to the energy industry it's
wrong to focus on nuclear energy and
it's wrong to
increase include it completely there are
much more
environmentally friendly and cheaper
alternatives to nuclear energy
which would make us clean climate
neutral we need a french presidency
which will bring us together over the
next months rather than putting french
industry
above the general well
well-being you have the chance of
looking at the conference on the future
of europe and making it a genuine
success
but
the time for just
declarations is passed it's good that
you said that on the right of initiative
the european parliament you would fight
together with the german party but don't
leave it at that you need to ensure
there's greater transparency in the
council and ensure that we have european
law with the transnational force thank
you
thanks so much um sir macron um i
prepared my speech in estonia but you
know like sometimes it's like easier to
talk you directly because just direct
about your comments first of all you are
pretty much
a tactical and hungry about the rule of
law
we have to remind that all discussions
started 2015-16 when poland refused to
participate in the common immigration
policy
and nobody didn't care in brussels that
the migration policy has been always
part of the member states policy it's
not part of the eu policy
secondly we are attacking the court
system that is too political
i just checked in belgium the charges in
the constitutional court half of the
judges are appointed by the government
political government
and thirdly if we are attacking about
rule of law poland and hungary and the
same time you and mr macron few weeks
ago just said publicly that you're gonna
piss off all the people who are not
vaccinated
i thought that vaccination is free
it's good if you recognize it but nobody
can't blame on you nobody can't fire you
nobody can't put you like the punishment
if you're not vaccinated it's the
freedom of choice and we thank you mr
madison that's china thank you very much
one minute now go ahead
thank you madam president
a confederal europe with common goals
for foreign policy for the economy for
the culture for defence
but which doesn't violate the
sovereignty of the nations making it up
that was the idea of one of your
predecessors
president de gaulle
unfortunately
it hasn't been his idea mr macron that
has gone forward my group and i will
fight democratically but firmly against
a european superstate which reduces our
nations
to
minor administrative entities dominated
by
a
faceless bureaucracy we also refuse the
hypocrisy of wanting to tackle illegal
immigration by closing internal borders
so nobody can move from france to italy
but at the same time
imposing on italy
and states of first entrance the need to
keep their borders open to the outside
world
europe will never be one state
it is a civilization though to be loved
to protect and to hand down to our
children which is what we're fighting
for
[Music]
the program of the french presidency
looks at a
question of armament and european
military with the involvement of the
greek government and it's looking at
areas of huge geostrategic importance
this is a risk therefore for the
european union
and it's links with
with china in the indo chinese area as
well and
basically we're only looking at the
question of the french presidency um in
terms of capitalism
peoples are
fighting the pandemic throughout the eu
and suffering its consequences but the
french presidency is further undermining
the situation and its effects on health
so we have to pull together to face the
increase in prices which is a result of
liberalization of energy
we have to look at the question of
digital rules we have to look at the
question of teleworking and
the president
interrupts
thank you madam president president
macron
we have major challenges over the next
six months the pandemic we
in fact want vaccination under europe of
health faced with the economic crisis we
support our industry
our workers are self-employed our
farmers we therefore need to effectively
use the next generation funds to
modernize
the economy and jobs we need controlled
transparency and correct and rapid
disbursement of funds it's unacceptable
for governments like spain to not have
dispersed half of the funds of the eu
for 2021 when we have the highest
unemployment rate in spain president
macron
europe is inexplicably absent
internationally you didn't mention latin
america when that should be a strategic
area for europe if we don't pay
attention to it other actors who don't
share our values will take our place
international policy as you know
empty seats don't exist
let's recover and let's reinforce our
role in the world
says helen fritzon for one minute
mr president
i welcome the priorities of the french
presidency
but eu work shouldn't just be about
words it should be about action action
now and therefore there's a heavy
responsibility on your shoulders
president
there's an ongoing pandemic we still
need to cooperate we need to make sure
that more people get vaccinated the eu
also needs to take measures in order to
help us with the green transition it's a
matter of urgency and furthermore we
must make sure that we have gender
mainstreaming a third of women in europe
have no work
women and girls are subject to violence
every single day it's time for a europe
of equality now we cannot wait another
few decades finally
i come from sweden you've spoken about
minimum wage you've spoken also about
each national model being respected
that's very important for us in sweden
and for our model thank you
next is charles for one minute
madam president president of the council
of the union of the 27 heads of state
and government there is a majority
who let's be honest
uh really uh have not really gone too
far in promoting european integration
those
who
play politics when it's time to do it
and let's also not forget the question
of the rule of law that those people
seem to try to make people believe that
region of mandalay in moscow and
brussels will be the same thing and then
uh i would say that van der line is one
of the only people who is adopting a
pro-european um
stance along with the president who has
taken over the uh
the council presence in the first of
january he is projecting a future for
our citizens in europe for our countries
and for our continent president macron
was brave enough to make europe a major
stakes in his electoral campaign in 2017
we can learn from him that in politics
we constantly have to preempt
despite the current projects let's dare
to work together in order to make europe
stronger better protected more dynamic
next is geralt's animals for one minute
[Applause]
president macron i can understand
clearly that for the french presidency
of the council
the presidential elections in france are
also going to be important
and there are subjects that will not
satisfy everybody and this will have an
impact on debate in general
and i'm afraid that's the case for the
whole of the european union
quite clearly
you are going to use the presidency of
the eu for domestic political purposes
and i'm worried this will have
an impact on french presidential
elections you'll be imposing your vision
on the legal system of the eu
this jacobin system that you want to
impose on all of the european nations
the kind of federalism or as we saw in
with the agreement with the german
government
this kind of german federation
which
actually
is leading to federalism european
federalism if that's your vision i
cannot say i agree with it and on behalf
of my group
i will be opposing that
we have to try to keep up with the time
i apologize
go ahead martin
thank you madam president mr macron
when i first heard you present the
priorities of the french presidency on
the 9th of december last year i was
struck by the sincere passion with which
you talked about regaining european
sovereignty defending its values and
interests a few days later however you
visited viktor orban in budapest who not
only disregards the european values that
you seek to defend but act as a trojan
horse in undermining its sovereignty and
geopolitical interest echoing moscow's
position at a time when putin conducts a
military offensive at our borders adopts
cold war rhetoric and revives the
brezhnev doctrine by outlining its
spheres of influence in an ultimatum
like stalin did in yalta
how do you wish to go about attaining
european sovereignty given the apparent
challenges that pro-russian illiberalism
poses and what reforms do you propose in
our institutions and procedures to
further your objectives thank you thank
you very much mr gyangyoshi next is
vangelis mae maracas for one minute
president of the french republic i wish
you the best of luck because the
challenges that the french presidency is
called on to
face
and then the crisis in europe and the
entire world are unprecedented and cover
many dimensions the question of
migration faced by the countries in the
south particularly my country greece and
also the nice need to strengthen the
external borders of the eu are basic
aims of the french presidency we will
all work together over the next six
months to achieve those aims i would
like to stress to you that today
we've also received the rafale planes in
greece to help strengthen and protect
our borders so
the aims of the
french presidency match with many of our
challenges but we have to try and
address the crisis through european
policies which will stand the test of
time
so the changes which you are aiming to
bring about in the french presidency are
also a clear
message to those who are facing us thank
you
for one minute
[Applause]
europe shall be social or it shall not
be in french
it's not a coincidence
it's not a coincidence that that
particular dictum comes from the french
language i think it's part and parcel of
any french presidency you always talk
about social europe and i completely
agree
inequality
inequality
is
a threat to us recent studies have shown
quite clearly
that covet really has accentuated
inequality that's why it's so important
for us to have this flagship project for
fair minimum wage something that will
really make a contribution to our
taxpayers to their pockets so to speak
to make sure that they have work that
they are paid correctly and to make sure
that they have a good uh
policy when it comes to remuneration so
the french presidency and indeed our
parliament need to be up to the mark we
need to meet that obligation
you referred also to mr schumann you
talked about creative efforts on that
point allow me to ask you to also refer
to regulation 883 and social security we
need to have creative thinking there too
thank you says valerie hire for one
minute
madam president president of the
republic welcome to the hemi cycle
colleagues
we're here
uh not at the national assembly or in a
campaign meeting we're at the european
parliament here to change the life of
europeans
not just to
speak out as
president as campaigners
or in this hemicycle without having any
answers to our questions some people
here though clearly haven't understood
i refuse
that this debate which is so important
for europe should be undermined by bad
faith you cannot
complain that the presidency
hasn't been moved and at the same time
say that we're not moving fast enough in
moving forward you cannot claim that
france is isolated whilst your own
political groups share the political
aims of this french presidency
you cannot take hostage the european
idea for your own political calculations
president of the republic you are in
friendly territory here you have a solid
majority to transform europe along your
terms thank you next to paulo angel for
one minute
you madam president mr president
i would like to wish every success to
the french presidency
your
speech highlighted two shortcomings
reform of the schengen agreement you
mentioned external borders rightly
but with the pandemic i think the
internal borders are also put in a
crisis situation
we have a schengen space
which has been scattered and i think the
question we have to ask is what is the
vision of the french presidency to
re-establish freedom of circulation in
the internal schengen area and not just
at the external borders
i didn't hear any ideas from the french
presidency either for the future of
economic and monetary union
investment was mentioned but not a road
map for the future of emu
there were a lot of words good
intentions but no action merciless
president in your speech you mentioned
mr pessoa the
portuguese poet if i can respond by
saying
mollier
you have to be flexible
inaudible i'm afraid mrs belker one
minute
madam president
president of the french republic
in mid-2020 the french and dutch
ministers published a non-paper on the
social
and sustainability aspects of eu trade
policy
it called for the increased efforts by
the commission and the member states to
implement ambitious environmental and
labor standards as well as
sustainability criteria into the
functioning of the international trading
system
and to encourage responsible business
conduct
over 18 months later we can appreciate
that many of those calls have been
transformed into priorities of the
french presidency
however we miss more details on the fate
of one important legislation
the sustainable corporate governance
directive has been already twice
withheld from publication by the
commission
and yet the presidency program refers to
this legislation as a future
initiative well the future is now and
the french presidency should take
concrete actions to make this
legislation a reality thank you thank
you very much uh mr belka before i pass
on to mr verhofstadt i would like to
announce that we now open the second
ballot in the election of the questers
and as there is one seat to be filled
you can only dear colleagues vote for
one candidate so i declare the vote open
until quarter past three and we will
announce the results at four o'clock
mr perhaps that i took a little bit of
time now so i'll give you a little bit
of flexibility on that go ahead you have
the floor
take it from my time i will not take it
from your time i promise i'll take it
from my own
president
you'll have seen that most of our french
colleagues are absolutely obsessed about
the french elections presidential
elections
we've heard all the attacks mr bellamy
mrs ubri
and i forget some mr bomba
except of course mr zhadow i understand
that he's the only candidate officially
speaking in this chamber he is the only
candidate so i suppose he's still
enthusiastic it's just the beginning of
the presidential campaign
so hence the kind of discourse that
we've heard i mean
i thought maybe you were on radio or on
television on antendu or tfr i wasn't
quite sure when i listened to you
speaking anyway
what we don't need here is divisions
what we need for the next six months is
unity european unity mr shadow it's a
critical time for europe we're being
threatened from the inside look at
kaczynski look at urban we're being
threatened also from the outside
external threats by putin and therefore
what we need is unity not just in france
but in europe across the board and
therefore president
i would say to you whatever happens
whatever you need to do in europe
we know that european citizens support
you thank you
i give the floor next for one minute to
esther de lange
[Applause]
thank you madam president and first of
all congratulations to you it's an
absolute pleasure to have you and to
have a woman once again at the head of
this institution
let me also thank the french president
for his committed passionate and
pro-european speech as we have come of
course to expect from this french
president and i thank him for his
european commitment he has stated at the
beginning of this year that the french
presidency must be a turning point for
europe
but let me be clear
only ambition and commitment are not
enough we also need credibility
a dancer context mr president
and in this context mr president i
wonder as i'm sure many do if your
budget policy your public spending
are really in the interests of france
and europe or rather in the interests of
your own re-election campaign i've had
to address the economic fallout of the
covet crisis and the eu you mentioned it
took the historic decision to establish
its rrf and yes we need to have a debate
about the smartest way to shape and
apply our budgetary rules but even
before kovit france has never breached
budgetary rules as much as during the
first year of this president's mandate
europe mr president first and foremost
needs to france that is ready for
reforms so that we can build this
stronger europe together thank you very
much
thank you very much mr lange i give the
floor next for one minute to oro la luke
thank you madam president
president macron at european level
if you you can impose nuclear power you
can impose anything but really i think
we need to know what france genuinely
wants specifically concurrently and i
would insist on those terms because at
european level france does excellent
speeches flurries of rhetoric but when
it comes to implementation it's a bit
more difficult
and
what we don't want to see is the
watering down of directives or treaties
on taxation on banking for example or
taxonomy so the question is a simple one
whether france will defend
reform and ambitious reform of the
stability and growth pact with the same
strengths it did the inclusion of
nuclear
or are we going to exclude
functioner's salaries from budgets
because
we need investment in health and
education and so on or are we going to
make everything slightly less ambitious
and
let's hope everything works for the best
for one minute
madam president mr president
do you really believe that these three
promises democracy progress and peace do
you really think that this can happen if
europe doesn't become an opportunity for
all with all the people who live in
rural areas millions of them you know
they can't just cross the street in
order to get a job or to have access to
a hospital sometimes they have to travel
a long distance and indeed they have to
pay a price for that which is
increasingly high for transport
so
what are we talking about here are we
talking about
re-routing democracy are we talking
about abandoning people
we need to make sure that people have an
opportunity to improve their livelihoods
their families we see unfortunately that
europe is all about giving advantages to
those who already have assets who have
opportunities who have contacts
what is the absolute priority of your
presidency president you haven't talked
about 5g you haven't talked about public
transport not a word on that not a word
on farmers either i think that all
european citizens should be respected
whatever their color of skin whatever
their beliefs whatever their origins
wherever they might be geographically
speaking so we need to make a pro a
promise of social democratic progress
and that should be an opportunity for
all thank you so anies john harris for
one minute
and
president macron
thank you madam president president
macron i'm glad to see that we agree on
a major priority that's higher minimum
wages throughout the eu as far as i'm
concerned this is a crucial
recommendation because it means that we
can have european rules to ensure that
all europeans have a decent wage for the
work that they do
you don't seem to be wasting any time
and so we expect that you before the
summer will have adopted clear positions
in the essential areas for example the
adjusting of the object is 55 and you
take positions on that gas nuclear
energy
you say that they're sustainable
energies well our green
fact should not be brought into question
just to gain political points to
conclude child labour poor working
conditions unacceptable wages these are
realities we have to combat it can't be
delayed proposals have to be made in
specific terms so that we can face up to
our common responsibilities and we need
a clear council mandate on this front
thank you
madam president president micron
a parliamentary assembly is always
sensitive to the magic of words and you
are a talented magician mr president
but there comes a point in time
when what is said
doesn't hide
ambiguities and contradictions anymore
so
there are those who believe the
president today who respects the freedom
of peoples their sovereignty that's the
word that you used and the other
president who for four years now
has been theorizing about a divide which
is presented as being irrecoverable
between the populists who are bad
authoritarians
and on the other hand the progressive
virtuous progressives who are federalist
well who believes in either of those
presidents i don't see myself in either
of those categories can we have
confidence in somebody who
justifiably
does in fact talk of the rule of law
which is a noble principle but who in
his country for two years has been
managing a health crisis not with his
parliament and his government
who just channel what he wants for the
last two years but instead a council of
defense and security which is not the
right body for this and whose
deliberations are carried out in secrecy
in defense issues
president
there may be a consensus so why do you
use this formula you've done more in two
years than others in twenty or fifty
progress has been made towards a europe
of defence which has got double the
funds originally planned but there has
been backsliding we're not going to have
european executive operations haven't
since 2008
and can't mount a robust military
operation today whereas we could 20
years ago in africa
so president contradictions ambiguities
that can't be swept away but we see this
presidency as being one that's a highly
responsible one because the timing is
such
that i give the floor next to rafael
glucksman for one minute
president sometimes crimes can be so big
and criminals can be so powerful that
they can't find room in a long speech
you talked about human rights generally
speaking but you ignored the worst crime
against humanity of today namely the
eradication
and the annihilation of the oigo people
what is the point in all this if we
don't defend them we have millions of
human beings who have been put into
camps to be courageous to be strong is
to stand by the sight of those who are
weak not just those who are strong
otherwise we are being cowardly you have
nike zara volkswagen they actually are
multinationals who benefit from the
situation this is slavery this is
markets courage would mean standing up
for the hundreds of thousands of young
people who would like you to act
the only time
in your mandate when you talked about
the oights was when you said france
cannot do anything on its own only
europe can act on this issue now you are
at the head of our union and still i
hear not a single word about this crisis
that's the problem we know the
principles we know human rights we
defend human rights what we're lacking
here is courage courage to actually
stand up for these rights vis-a-vis a
powerful opponent thank you uh for all
the contributions i now give the floor
to vice president zefkovich on behalf of
the commission
thank you very much madam president mr
president honorable members first and
foremost i really would like uh to thank
uh all honorable members and uh mr
president for what was really uh very
rich debate very detailed answers
and reaction i think through testimony
to the european democracy and i think if
you look at the
number of topics we've been discussing
today
ranging from the hard security challenge
to the east
of our borders
issues of social fairness
economic and climate policy migration
down to the
economy and the need for strategic
autonomy all this just testifies
what kind of crucial times we are living
in
and in what kind of crucial time mr
president both presidents is arriving uh
to hat
the european union
therefore allow me just one personal
point on the issue where we are now or
where we have been five or six years ago
because sometimes i think it's worth to
recall to remember how was it and i
remember it very vividly because at that
time we've been very much worried also
in this house that it could be some
european anti-european wave sweeping
across our countries across our european
union we've been worried that we will
have more exits
from the european union
and we've been very much concerned about
the possible weakening of the european
cooperation
and i have to say mr president that uh
your commitment to europe
your commitment
to france to the people of france and
european countries presented under the
tune of european anthem in paris
changed the mood
i would say that it changed the
political course
and we know how badly we needed it at
that time
because it brought us new ambition new
courage new hope a new determination
to build europe we should be stronger
better prepared for the future
challenges and i think this was the
debate
this morning
focused on how we can do that
i'm glad that the vulnerable members
many of them been very fair because a
lot has been done we never had such a
transformative transformative budget
transformating transformative funding as
we have with the next generation of
europe we clearly demonstrated that if
it comes to the vaccination that europe
if it pulls as one can really deliver
what i would describe the miracles just
let's remember where we have been a year
and a half ago and what kind of dramatic
debates we had in
in this house
we adopted a commitment the first
continent in the world to be climate
neutral
and we are working a lot and delivering
in the area of the defense we are
working a lot on strategic autonomy uh
terry breton is sitting with us all the
time he's working a lot about
new technologies and what i'm very glad
on we are focusing much more on the
future of europe than we have been in
the past
so what i would like
to conclude on is that i agree with all
those vulnerable
members who are very clear demanding and
rightly so that we should do more and we
should deliver it faster it should be
more actionable more result oriented and
of course the the the question is how to
do that i i'm glad to say that a lot of
the proposals which are addressing the
core issues which have been repeated in
the interventions of many uh vulnerable
members are addressed with the proposals
already put on the table by the european
commission and what we need is and here
i totally agree with mr hofstadt we need
unity we need a close collaboration and
cooperation with the european parliament
and we need ambitious presidencies
and messenger president i think that you
represent such an ambitious uh
presidency presidency presidency which
is focused
on a strategic delivery on the future
and which is committed to the concrete
results and i just would like to say on
the behalf of the commission that we are
ready to work with you as closely as
possible hand in hand because success of
your presidency will be successful
europe it will be successful france and
therefore we should focus on the close
cooperation and uh
close coordination as much as possible
may celebrate
madame president honourable members
thank you very much
thank you very much vice president
sefcovich
[Applause]
for
to conclude the debate mr president
you have the flaw
i know that uh
it'll probably be your pleasure to
answer the questions
in a comprehensive speech thank you
madam president i will at least try to
come back to the main points that were
raised and thank you very much to
everybody
that has taken the floor
i would like to start by introducing
minor clarifications i have never
actually said that loving europe means
you can't love a national identity and
culture
but i would distinguish between those
that love their country and culture
i would distinguish between those and
those that want to destroy europe
i think that actually there is a
majority here for example who believe in
europe but also the cultures and
identities of each country but who still
fight against the
barbarics of nationalism
there is a distinction so i think we
should avoid any form of confusion yes
to europe and a desire for europe which
you have always heard me defend which
respects cultures and identities but
which is firm in its principles
fighting against divisions which lead to
national egotisms
which just repeat history and if you
have political forces that have
expressed themselves in our countries on
these points i would listen to them but
five years ago the french chose in the
second round of the presidential
elections who did they choose which were
the two political forces
which were at the top of the running in
france
because yes those who represented that
divide i don't want to name them but
there is a divide that was clear today
with men and women coming from different
countries in europe with political
convictions which send you back to
nationalism so i would distinguish
between a love of identity and culture
patriotism which is not nationalism and
europe and federalism i would
distinguish between the two and you have
never heard me meps either
support any form of european uh racism
of any form
and
i try to walk a path from the start to
the end i believe in european
civilization the strength of our culture
i've always defended that vehemently and
you have spoken some of you about words
words have a meaning and i don't want
those to be
misrepresented on french industry that
was destroyed by 12 years but to 20 29
onwards we are seeing
it coming back that's just a fact then
the temporary reopening of coal mines
that were plants that were closed
temporarily yes there were two plants
that were totally closed and two that
were temporarily closed due to delays
partly because of supply problems again
facts
so i just wanted to make those points
clear
various points were raised by various
members of the european parliament
managing the pandemic most of the member
state states
has meant in most
european countries they've used
provisions special laws states of
emergency which have had an effect on
the way in which our countries work
in all men in all european states
that
has
led
to
fair
constitutional
controls and involvement of judges let's
not control managing a health crisis
and questions of rule of law please if
you take the case of france i would
defend the actions of the government
under the law it falls to the council of
defense and national security to deal
with pandemics under french legislation
which led to a dozen texts sent to
parliament by the president which used
its right of amendment and then which
were judged by constitutional
judges anyone who loves europe should
defend it with rigor and i do i defend
rule of law in my country too
and constitutionally too i accept that
responsibility
then there were questions that were
asked of me about journalists
that was important and here i would like
to come back to one point
rapidly
about the attacks on several journalists
first of all we want to make progress on
a framework to make journalists safer
as a part of procedures against all
forms of intrusion
and quality of information and i think
regulating platforms will make that
possible but also a journalism fund
which will make it possible to make
support to make progress here we need a
fund to provide support for journalists
that will
complete and complement the text that
the commission will be sending to the
parliament in the next few days to
improve firstly our collective
organizations
and then alert mechanisms as well as the
necessary investment to provide better
protection
quite clearly we want to
reinforce on the one hand the
independence of the media but also their
means of protecting themselves against
any form of intrusion such as those we
have already suffered and will continue
to suffer then questions on posted
workers
saying we had done nothing once again
i would actually ask the member to look
at what has actually happened and the
work that is underway collectively we
have introduced a reform of posted
workers in 2017
limiting
posted work to 12 months and combating
letterbox firms which
and a principle to of the same salary
for the same work in the same place
avoiding therefore posted work being
used as a form of unfair competition
that is a genuine step forward i think
in organizing work as you seem to
indicate posted work was by definition
bad
but
that is the very heart of an integrated
market and france is one of the main
countries that sends out posted workers
so i think it's difficult for us to
defend our posted workers who live and
work in other countries
if we are to be against posted workers
from other countries coming to our
country i think this is where
nationalism actually has nothing to say
and we need european cooperation we're
not at the end of work here we have to
work on social security contributions
and benefits and we are negotiating this
with the regulation of with the revision
of regulation
843 and indeed colleagues did point out
that there were issues here and i do
agree with your ambition we want to
ensure this goes further this was
blocked at the end of 2021 we want to
ensure that we have mobility of benefits
and contributions and we hope that we
will get
this through we will be working very
hard on that because we think it's a
vital
plank underpinning the structure of
reform
various members spoke
about the fact that we need to show
vigilance and thank you for having
recalled this and i say this with great
humility because
there was a pottier law in france
whereby we have a provision as of 2017
whereby we have a system of vigilance
and we would like europe to adopt a
similar system we would like the
commission to put forward a proposal
asap
we know work has been done so we are
awaiting a commission proposal in the
next week so that at european school we
can set down obligations for european
companies on their value chains
respecting human rights the environment
which will mean that i can come back to
another question raised and companies
will be submitted to reporting
requirements our desire is that this
commission proposal be provided asap and
that it can go to the different
institutions and be worked on them asap
we also want to make progress on other
subjects i don't want us to forget
non-financial reporting of companies and
investors too
whereby we can set genuine standards for
responsibility and due diligence trilog
will be starting this week and that is a
very important point making it possible
again to obtain
very specific concrete results and that
is totally in line with the point you
raised i also wanted to come back
clearly to
fighting uh fraud
you mentioned that point and the fact
that again we need to make progress too
on the work that wasn't in fact
concluded on minimum tax of
multinationals and we do hope
that we will be able to get all the
agreements necessary and to finalize
this work over the next few weeks and i
share the level of ambition raised here
then there was a question that was put
about schengen once again romania like
bulgaria and now croatia
are
want to join schengen preparatory work
has been done and that's been recognized
by all the member states and the
procedure is going hand in hand with the
reforms we'll be
launching in a few weeks which will make
it possible once again to guarantee the
protection of all the external borders
and on schengen i would say quite
clearly on the one hand we have a
proposal from the commission from
december whereby we can better defend
the internal borders which was the point
that was raised a while ago and we hope
to conclude on that subject
and i would like to reiterate the fact
that our desire is to make progress on
all of these points as i said earlier
in taking over
responsibility for the tools we have
available to us like frontex and the
borders agency and using
intergovernmental cooperation to beef up
the borders and in concluding as well
the system that we have for cooperation
on borders well that means that we can
more effectively
introduce returns for example to
countries of origin and i think we are
not sufficiently effective as things
stand on this point
and i think we will manage to introduce
reforms which will make us more
effective in europe i also had questions
put to me on russia
i think i answered earlier
i think our credibility
vis-a-vis russia
lies primarily in entering into
uh demanding dialogue and we see that
looking at the dialogue that the us and
russia are currently undertaking
i think that it is good for there to be
coordination between europe and the us
but it is vital that europe has its own
dialogue with russia
it's also true that our collective
security
arms
on our territories is a european issue
too
so we have to conclude a common position
on the new world order for europe for
security and stability as i mentioned
and then collectively two
we have to work on areas where we are
vulnerable as various of you have
mentioned because the credibility of our
response does require
a certain amount of codependence whereby
we can mutually reinforce cooperation
amongst ourselves
avoiding therefore such vulnerabilities
and on energy issues for example this is
vital we've been reactive about this in
the last few months but we have seen too
that this is something that can be used
by regimes hybrid attacks
we've seen migration movements being
manipulated we've seen cyber attacks
we've seen hikes in gas prices and on
this front we need to build in
collective resilience
together lucidly i'd also like to
reassure people about farmers and people
living in the rural world i don't think
at all that they have nothing to do with
the europe that we
are talking about on the contrary when
talking about our cap
our farmers on the ground know to what
extent they need europe and it's thanks
to this european policy that we can make
progress and we also know collectively
that as it's linked the is the
solidarity investment policy that we had
during the crisis has made it possible
for us to make progress so the policies
that we have the european policies that
permit these major
investments in infrastructure and
immobility europe is a major contributor
and i wouldn't forget that
various people have also mentioned
macroeconomic reforms
incidentally
you've referred to this with some
nuances some differences and i think
that reflects your political vantage
point of course
including france
and including also the fact that some of
you thought that this was a new policy a
great opening
a kind of reinvention of the categories
that we used to have in the past in
terms of expenditure and others who
argued that this was a matter of coming
back to budgetary rules that used to
prevail prevail in the past either all
now first of all as the presidency of
the council for this uh semester i don't
want to anticipate what we might have to
say on this issue the discussions that
are still to come but i would like to
clarify a couple of points if i may as
far as i know in our texts in our
instruments we've never had a myth or a
cult of zero deficit zero debt
also because in the rate environment
that we live in that would be
counter-cyclical actually also i would
like to reiterate that france before the
crisis reduced its public deficit
several of you mentioned this coming out
of the excessive deficit procedure 2017
and we really brought that down quite
significantly and also brought down
taxation whilst introducing reforms so
we talked about a magic potion earlier
on i wanted to pick up on that and i
wanted to tell you that in this period
of crisis we still have our
insurance policy against unemployment
nobody else had done that and therefore
i think that this is certainly a
philosophy that i will stand by i will
support it i don't want people to mock
france on the contrary this is a
question of of an effort a genuine
effort made by all french people all
french citizens
now the next question can we come out of
this crisis and can we come back to
status quo ante where we were before
well first of all collectively in this
crisis we actually had far fewer
divergences than we did last time around
last time we had a crisis in the
previous financial crisis which then
became a sovereign debt crisis we
actually saw europe being splintered it
split apart
this time we have a solidarity-based
investment system in practically all of
our countries were all agreed and these
policies are monitored assessed and for
those of you who are concerned about
france let me tell you that a nobel
peace nobel prize winner a few days ago
said that the french solution was not
amongst the the worst you could have not
at all
and then let me also tell you that we
have a policy we've all invested into
this in order to support our economies
and then europe has also invested with
own resources in order to move even
further forward and i think that that
was the right choice the right policy
because the other policy
when we had the financial crisis that
was the other policy that we conducted
and then we actually made the
adjustments domestically at national
level there was a fragmentation monetary
reply was slow to come and we had
different budgetary policies so what
happened then europe took
a lot longer than the united states of
america coming out of that crisis years
more even though we did not cause the
crisis we actually weakened our own
productive capacity and we actually
achieved a kind of
divergence of different
economic policies that's not the case
today and in fact france has come back
to its gdp figures and therefore
collectively speaking i would like to
stand by the policy that we have rolled
out now in terms of coming out of this
crisis i don't want to anticipate yet
again but i'd like us to look at this in
light of the strategies that we've all
depended defended sorry depending on our
our vantage point nevertheless we've
said we have to invest in in the fight
against climate change we all said we
need reforms we need uh bans you might
have disagreements as to the pacing of
this and as to how we should go about it
but we certainly have to invest
innovation our productive
industries we need to of course stand by
some territories particularly rural
areas
the middle classes and also the working
classes
we need to stand by them of course and
for all of that we need to make a common
investment and in order to get a more
high-tech europe a technological europe
we need to have investments national
investments and also european
investments and also stronger defense i
agree we should go further but for that
we need to put money on the table we
need to make investments and again
look at the different countries look at
greece for instance greece is
shouldering a lot of the european
expenditure here some of us are very far
from the two percent and yet it's all
about collective security that's what
we're working towards so we need to look
at the budgetary terms as well and so
therefore yes i am in favor of having
investments we need these investments
and we can have a common analysis what
are the investments that we could you
know take from the private sector and i
think i've mentioned that taxonomy by
the way is part and parcel of that and
then there's another part if we want to
go sufficiently quickly ahead if we want
to be there stand by people then we need
to have public investments as well state
investments so there's a mass of public
investment which we need if we want to
be ambitious on climate on military
aspects on social aspects on industrial
aspects we need to be there we need to
step up to the plate whether it's
community whether it's national that's
the debate that we're going to have and
we need to have the right instruments in
hand in order to reach that target
that's the debate and that is what will
conduct leaders sorry to a new
macroeconomic policy with the
investments priority investment on all
of these big areas that i've talked
about either at community level or at
domestic level
in a different way but one way or
another we'll need to come up with the
funding we'll need to come up with the
financing and that whether that's
community finding new funding sorry with
new owned resources in order to finance
this this these policies that's one
thing all domestically with national
funding
that's the debate that we're going to
have we know that this generation is
really facing a turning point from that
point of view i was also asked about
another issue
namely regional languages and
multilingualism
and
you know that the minister of foreign
affairs of france is a a defender a
champion of these rights linguistic
rights first of all we very much hold by
these principles of multilingualism in
the european institutions i'm going to
say this here and here and now in front
of the european parliament we're in
defense of the french language of course
and in addition to that
we must not forget you know what it was
that lay at the very foundations of
europe post brexit etc you are if you
like the embodiment of that multiplicity
also regional aspects have their have
their room in all this have their place
in all this i'm not sure how you
interpret the legal decisions that you
you talked about earlier i don't want to
interfere in domestic legal proceedings
in spain but we certainly believe that
regional languages shall be respected
you know that
in france of course french is the only
official language but through education
through a proactive policy that we
should continue to pursue i think we
also want to make sure that regional
identities can be expressed can can be
lived a lived experience i'm also in
favor of being ambitious when it comes
to the south american continent several
of you uh mentioned this quite rightly
so i forgot to to mention it myself in
may yes indeed we intend to hold
together with our colleagues in spain
and in portugal we want to hold an
informal summit on the south american
continent and we want to talk about our
partnerships on that occasion so thank
you very much for recording the
importance of that event i
look forward to it and then the final
few points if i may uh joint military
operations
you in a way you might have surprised me
here mr danjong in your speech
you know this area very well indeed and
at the beginning of my term of office i
was able to rely on your expertise in
order to draw up a strategy document
which helped us pave the way for a new
french law on this particular aspect so
you know the situation very well indeed
and you know that france is very
committed to this here and in europe
and let me reply to you therefore sir
yes we still have joint military
operations we do this together in the
mediterranean in the uh our arab gulf uh
persia and also of course the task force
in cuba
so for all of these operations we are
talking about joint military operations
and incidentally let me point out that
this was done upon at the behest of our
greek colleagues and and in cooperation
with them you know we've always worked
together with you i can tell you france
is very much
devoted to this concept together with
you so we launched these operations
together we're also
uh procuring collectively for our
equipment
you know in terms of the rule of law
i've said what i've had to say but on
defense i can also state quite clearly
what i what my opinion is you know we
don't have enough um
we don't have enough uh distance between
what's happened in the past and today i
would like to commend the initiatives
taken by germany france others
i would like to also talk about
the permanent structured corporation
that we now have which set it up some
years ago now we still have
projects
up and running the twista et cetera i
won't list them all we also have a
european defense fund which we have set
up together
with principles common principles we
fought for that and i agree i agree with
you we could go a lot further it's not
the end of the story and i'm relying on
your support i'd like us to go further
to make these rules even more robust to
make them genuinely european but we are
the main investors when it comes to
research and technology in europe in
that particular place and we know that
the commission is working with us
closely and we all know how important it
is also we have a common uh cultural
strategy with a european initiative for
intervention proposed at the salbon
10 countries or so have decided to sign
up to this so that's another example and
thanks to the work done by the high
representative we'll be able to bring
that particular
compass project to an end as well
to completion
and
these are a series of projects that i'm
listing here before you just to
illustrate my point you can indeed
cite such examples and like yourself i
believe in action rather than words and
i believe in fact i believe in realities
rather than grand declarations grant
statements finally a question was put to
me on the issue of china and on the
massacre of the oigo community
i turned to the honourable member and
you were quite right to talk about
deportation about forced labor and about
these attacks first of all i agree with
what you said uh you know the fact that
there are several brands uh that have
been affected by this crisis and we now
have a framework in france in order to
move forward on these issues in terms of
corporations
that you're quite right to mention that
secondly you know that france every time
is very clear bilaterally on these
issues and we were perfectly clear also
with chancellor merkel president michel
michelle president vander lyon
we raised this issue and we said that
this was a condition for the investment
agreement now why do i want to respond
to that particular point
in quite some detail you you talked
about your commitment and i wanted to
respond by saying this there's not going
to be an investment agreement if we
don't have ratification of the
conventions of the ilo that would allow
us to
monitor and to ban of course forced
labor that's point number one point
number two and this is something that
was mentioned by several of your
colleagues on due diligence this is
precisely the instrument that will allow
us to implement what you're calling for
so let me state quite clearly before you
i am in favor of that this proposal
should be submitted as soon as possible
and i very much hope that it will be
finalized as soon as possible that we
will complete it we support it in france
we continue to apply it in france we
would like it to become an eu regulation
and i think that that is the framework
that will allow us to impose this
obligation on our businesses our
corporations also protect those
corporations that are
subscribing to due diligence principles
and as for the commission the commission
will also come forward with its proposal
for a text or it might have an ad hoc
approach but to ban the import of goods
that are the result of forced labor a
ban on such imports that is what europe
can do so let's do it
ladies and gentlemen these would be my
replies to your
questions comments
as i picked up on certain points that i
wanted to make perhaps more specifically
and respond to you
i was very happy and very proud to be
able to stand before you here today in
strasbourg in this parliament whom we
love so dearly
as do you and i would like to thank you
very much indeed for defending the
parliament in strasbourg
first of all because this is the spirit
and the letter of our texts
furthermore because the europe that we
believe in is a europe that doesn't have
a single center it is actually a
polycentric europe
you have fillers pillars which are
present in different countries
and therefore
i believe that the presence of the
european parliament in strasbourg and
the progress that we've been able to
make and i would like to thank all of
the teams the secretary general and the
teams that have really helped us these
last few weeks and months you know that
france has really made an investment in
order to provide good working conditions
with new premises allowing you to work
better and to be welcomed even better
here in strasbourg it's because we
believe in this and we believe that this
is the europe that we want to defend the
values that we want to defend our
mirrored in this european parliament in
strasbourg so that is what i wanted to
say thank you i believe in europe of
ambitions and that is what we need we
need a unified europe we need a europe
that stands together and i know that you
all know notwithstanding differences and
opinion that we've seen today and that
we can have of course amongst each other
but we know that we can have a
respectful dialogue we can have
exchanges sometimes moot points
sometimes controversial points but
nevertheless we can come to good
compromises ones that are ambitious ones
that allow us to build europe and to
take europe into the future take it
further respecting all differences
respecting also the fact that we
sometimes agree to disagree but at the
same time we're always seeking new
agreements so thank you very much for
your kind attention honourable members
mercy
may see
[Applause]
thank you to you mr president into all
college
you